und damit kommen wir jetzt zum
Einzelplan des Bundesministeriums für
Ernährung und Landwirtschaft
7,25 Milliarden Euro sind dafür
eingeplant der Großteil dieses
Einzelplans
beinhaltet die landwirtschaftliche
Sozialpolitik denn die Landwirte
erhalten ja vom Bund Zuschüsse zur
Alterssicherung aber auch Zuschüsse zu
ihrer
Krankenversicherung
da sind
insgesamt knapp fünf Milliarden Euro
dafür eingeplant zu mir der
bundesernährungs und
Landwirtschaftsminister kann wird das
auch noch mal in dieser Debatte
ausführen er ist allerdings erst in
Mitte der Debatte angekündigt lässt erst
einmal alle Fraktionen hier einmal
sprechen das ist ja auch so dass die
Ministerin und Minister nicht gleich am
Anfang sprechen weil manche dort sich
erst einmal anhören wollen was so an
Kritik kommt und dann können Sie darauf
reagieren unter anderem zum Beispiel
vielleicht auch was zum Tierwohl Label
gesagt wird dass wurde jetzt eher hat
Tim Ötzi mir verteidigt erster Redner
aus der CDU ist jetzt Josef rief
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen sehr geehrter Herr Minister der
Regierungsentwurf für den Einzelplan 10
war bereits mehr als Enttäuschung es gab
aber noch Hoffnung dass sie den Haushalt
in den Haushaltsberatungen etwas mehr
für die deutschen Bauern und den
ländlichen Raum tun würden doch außer
Lippenbekenntnisse nichts
auch weiterhin
[Applaus]
auch weiterhin bleibt der Zuschuss zur
Unfallversicherung für die Landwirte um
77 Millionen reduziert die Betriebe
müssen jetzt 18 Prozent mehr
Versicherung zahlen die aufgestockten
EU-Hilfen hatten das in 2020 zwar etwas
abgefedert in 23 schlägt das ganze voll
zu wir stellen heute noch einmal den
Antrag Liebe Ampel Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das ist Ihre Chance heute eine
schlimme Fehlleistung zu heilen
sehr geehrter Herr Minister sie haben
mehr Tierwohl versprochen sie haben
gesagt sie machen das jetzt das
Gegenteil ist der Fall die völlig
unzureichenden 150 Millionen Euro aus
dem Regierungsentwurf müssen nun zu
einem Drittel für laufende Kosten der
Umstellung herhalten also Stellen stehen
nur 100 Millionen für den stallumbau zur
Verfügung und damit noch mal weniger ich
war auf der EuroTier und haben mir das
angeschaut wir brauchen so mindestens 30
Jahre bis alle Ställe modernisiert sind
so wird das nie ein Erfolgsprogramm
meine Damen und Herren die Bauern sollen
einen Porsche produzieren und der
Landwirtschaftsminister will nur ein
Mofa finanzieren so geht das nicht
sie hätten das Geld zusätzlich von Herr
Lindner holen müssen und sie verzichten
auf die Kofinanzierung der Länder die
automatisch über die GAK bis zu 40% dazu
gegeben hätten letztlich ist klar dass
sie mit ihrem Vorhaben scheitern werden
das hilft den Tiere nicht und ruiniert
die Bauern das verpflichtende Tierwohl
Label ohne zusätzliches Geld für die
Tierwohl Stelle heißt deutsches Fleisch
wird teurer und im Supermarkt liegt
ungeleiteltes billig Fleisch von
irgendwo auf der Welt und hat man ihnen
diese Woche bei Frau Maischberger
zugehört dann ist doch alles im Budde es
gibt große Probleme da stimmen wir zu
aber löse sie die lösen sie und wo es
klebt liegt es an der Größe des Rades
das gedreht werden muss
sie beklagen die Umsatzeinbußen in
Hofleben unser Vorschlag
Liquiditätshilfen für Direktvermarkter
und ökobetriege aufzulegen hat ihre
Koalition im Haushaltsausschuss sogar
zweimal abgelehnt eigene Lösung
Fehlanzeige es wäre ein Treppenwitz wenn
es Ihnen geht wie Kollegin Kühnast in
deren Ministerzeit
die meisten Betriebe aufgeben müssten
ihre Amtszeit könnte die Zeit sein in
der die meisten Öko-Betriebe aufgeben
müssen weil sie sie im Regen stehen
lassen
wir haben vorgeschlagen mit 100
Millionen der ausgabenrechte die im
Agrarhaushalt zu erwarten sind schnell
zu helfen ist darf doch nicht wahr sein
das in Zukunft noch mehr Bio-Produkte
aus dem Ausland kommen und wenn wir böse
wären würden wir haben Minister ihr
Handeln als Schaulaufen bezeichnen
deshalb zeigen sie ein Herz für unsere
Landwirtschaft die unter Energiepreisen
und Kriegsfolgen zu leiden hat und für
den ländlichen Raum sie kürzen die
Gemeinschaftsaufgabe Agrarstruktur und
küchenschützen nämlich gerade da wo es
um ländliche Raume geht das
Bundesprogramm ländliche Entwicklung
wird umbenannt bekommt 3 Millionen mehr
aber viel viel mehr Aufgaben und erst
von 2025 bis 30 soll es dann im Programm
tatsächlich auch wieder mehr Geld geben
die andere Kollegen feiern das in der
Fachpresse als hätte es die Mittel jetzt
gegeben das ist Augenwischerei den
langfristig soll das Budget des Bundes
Landwirtschaftsministers Stück für Stück
schrumpfen
wir brauchen jetzt ihren entschlossen
en ein sorgen sie für mehr Geld fürs
Tierwohl und eine Kofinanzierung der
Länder gehen Sie die
genehmigungsprobleme im Baurecht und
Emissionsschutz an sichern Sie Qualität
und Menge auf den Eckern und in den
Stellen ein Zögern und Zaudern lassen
wir Ihnen noch nicht nochmals durchgehen
gehen Sie die Probleme der
Ernährungswirtschaft schnell und
konsequent an sonst könnten sie als
Minister und die Ampelkoalition mit der
größten Anzahl an aufgebenden Betrieben
in Deutschland schlechte Geschichte
schreiben das wollen wir nicht und das
können auch Sie nicht wollen vielen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Josef rief kritisiert hier Kürzungen die
Unionsfraktion hat auch eine
Änderungsantrag eingereicht in dem sie
fordert die landwirtschaftliche
Unfallversicherung zu erhöhen also auch
dort mehr Geld einzuplanen Sebastian
Schäfer spricht nun für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
herr Präsident Herr Minister meinen
verehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
rief ich glaube ihr Schaulaufen hier
heute hat sie aufs Glatteis geführt und
mit dem rechnen das ist können wir ja
schon aus dem Haushaltsausschuss
die zeitenwände geht auch am Haushalt
des Bundesministeriums für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft nicht vorbei der
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
und die wirtschaftlichen Folgen die wir
insbesondere bei den hohen Preisen für
Energie und für Lebensmittel sehen
stellen unser Land und unsere
Gesellschaft vor große Herausforderungen
und gleichzeitig sehen wir die
Auswirkungen der Klimakrise immer
stärker zuletzt in diesem Sommer gerade
die Landwirtschaft ist davon extrem
betroffen immer häufigere
Starkregenereignisse immer längere
Dürreperioden zeigen uns doch wie
verletzlich unsere Landwirtschaft
gegenüber dem Klimawandel ist wer auf
der Seite der Landwirtinnen und
Landwirte steht der darf den
klimafreundlichen Umbau der
Landwirtschaft nicht weiter aufhalten
sondern muss ihn gestalten und
voranbringen und dies spiegelt sich in
diesem Haushalt wieder
ab dem kommenden Jahr fördern wir nun
den Umbau der Tierhaltung über ein
Bundesprogramm wir fangen mit der
Schweinehaltung an das ist ein erster
wichtiger Meilenstein hin zu einer
nachhaltigen und tierwohlorientierten
Tierhaltung das sind gute Nachrichten
für unsere Landwirte
aber nicht nur für unsere Landwirte auch
für die VerbraucherInnen für die Tiere
und nicht zuletzt für das Klima konkret
honorieren wir es zukünftig wenn unsere
Landwirte weniger Tiere besser halten
denn so leisten sie einen wichtigen
Beitrag für das Tierwohl den Klimaschutz
und das soll sich auch für die
Landwirtinnen und Landwirte lohnen
damit
zeigen wir als Ampel dass wir die
nutztierhalterinnen mit dieser großen
Aufgabe nicht alleine lassen sondern den
stallumbau aktiv fördern und damit eine
verlässliche Perspektive bieten bei der
Tierhaltung bleibt auch in den nächsten
Jahren noch viel zu tun um sie
zukunftsfähig zu machen in Deutschland
aber diese Regierung und dieser Minister
setzen endlich um was die Union früher
nur ins Schaufenster gestellt hat
außerdem haben wir in der
Bereinigungssitzung die Mittel für die
Zusammenarbeit mit der Welt
ernährungsorganisation sowie für
bilaterale kooperationsprogramme mit dem
auch mit dem Ausland deutlich
aufgestockt damit reagieren wir auf die
schwierige Situation bei der globalen
Ernährungssicherheit und in Welthunger
der sich durch die Folgen des brutalen
angriffskriegs Russlands auf die Ukraine
noch einmal verschärft hat so nehmen wir
auch unsere internationale Verantwortung
in dieser Krise war
sehr verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von der Union leider kann ich Ihnen
eines nicht ersparen über ihr agieren in
diesem parlamentarischen
Haushaltsverhandlungen musste ich mich
doch sehr wundern sie wollen bei der
Förderung der Betriebe wieder die
Gießkanne auspacken und was fällt Ihnen
bei der Gegenfinanzierung ein eine
Erhöhung der globalen Minderausgabe in
Zahlen gegossene Ideenlosigkeit
wie schrieb wie schrieb die Welt
bekanntermaßen ja das grüne hausblatt
diese Woche so treffend in der Tat kam
aus der Fraktion von CDU und CSU in den
vergangenen Monaten wenig wenn es um den
Haushalt ging da ist leider auch der
Einzelplan 10 keine Ausnahme
die Ampel stellt mit diesem Haushalt die
richtigen Weichen nicht nur der
ländliche Raum und die Wertschöpfung
dort werden eine gute Zukunft haben auch
der Wandel hin zu einer nachhaltigen
Landwirtschaft wird gelingen unsere
Landwirtinnen und Landwirte tragen mit
ihrer harten Arbeit elementar zu dieser
Wertschöpfung und zu unserer Ernährung
bei sie sind systemrelevant im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Schäfer
[Applaus]
Sebastian Schäfer ist wie auch die
nächste Rednerin Bericht Erstatter für
diesen Einzelplan und Ulrike Schielke
Ziesing ist das für die afd-fraktion
Präsident liebe Kollegen verehrte Bürger
bereits beim Vorliegen des
Haushaltsentwurfs 23 für den Bereich der
Landwirtschaft habe ich gesagt dass
dieser Bereich stiefmütterlich behandelt
wird leider haben die
Haushaltsberatungen an meiner
Einschätzung nichts geändert während man
noch beim Haushalt 22 ein bisschen
verstehen konnte dass die neue Regierung
sich noch etwas sucht gibt es diesmal
keine Ausreden mehr in ihrem Metall hat
die Koalition zwar ganz viele Anträge
gestellt aber diese waren eher
kosmetischer Natur vielfach wurden
Gelder nur etwas umgeschichtet und das
manchmal so kleinen Summen dass man die
glatt übersehen konnte insbesondere wenn
man bedenkt welche großen Summen
anderswo ausgegeben werden
substanziell wurde bei der
Landwirtschaft daher absolut nichts
geändert und es gäbe etwas zu erinnern
im Bereich der Landwirtschaft auch auf
Bundesebene was genau das haben wir mit
unseren Anträgen gezeigt etwa bei den
fehlenden fast 80 Millionen in der
landwirtschaftlichen Unfallkasse ihre
erste Amtshandlung als Ampel war es doch
diese Zuschüsse zu halbieren die Folge
die Beiträge der Landwirte Landwirte
stiegen um mehr als 18 Prozent die
Ausrede der Ampel so in etwa hat es die
Staatssekretärin formuliert wir setzen
das um was die groko vereinbart hat das
muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen
lassen ein grüner Minister setzt um was
schwarz rot vereinbart hat auf unsere
Argumente dass die Lage anders sondern
ist für die Landwirte ausgerechnet in
der jetzigen Situation ein Bären Dienst
ist kommen sie mit der Antwort das ist
ja eben bereits beschlossene Sache sei
das ist gelinde gesagt ein Armutszeugnis
für die Regierung
wo unsere Anträge anscheinend einen Nerv
getroffen haben waren die Hilfen in
Zusammenhang mit dem brexit insbesondere
in der Fischerei unsere Anträge haben
sie zwar wie üblich abgelehnt aber
immerhin sind die Berichterstatter der
Koalition doch noch aufmerksam geworden
und haben zumindest hier die
erforderlichen Ausgaben erhöht da helfen
wir als AFD doch immer gerne mit
Ratschlägen denn es soll nicht die
Landwirte die Last tragen nur weil die
Politik schlecht verhandelt hat wo sie
ruhig mal etwas mehr Ehrgeiz zeigen
könnten wäre bei den völlig ausgeuferten
Verwaltungsausgaben nur
maßgabebeschlüsse vorzulegen wo dann das
Haus aufgefordert wird ich zitiere
darauf hinzuwirken die
verwaltungsverfahrenskosten in den
nächsten Jahren zu reduzieren ist zwar
schöne gut aber als Haushälterin glaube
ich das erst wenn ich die Zahlen sehe
wie man als AFD auch gut bei der
Verwaltung und schlecht laufenden
Projekten sparen kann haben wir mit
unseren Anträgen ja aufgezeigt darin
wurden allein 116 Millionen für unnötige
Ausgaben gestrichen und was macht die
Ampel nicht mal ein Jahr im Amt und zwei
Haushalte später steigen die Ausgaben
beim Landwirtschaftsministerium und die
untergeordneten Behörden um sage und
schreibe 105 Millionen Euro so ein
Anstieg bei der Verwaltung hatten wir
noch nie anscheinend müssen wir viele
Parteikollegen und Lobby Vereine mit gut
dotierten Posten ausgestattet werden
zumindest in den anderen Einzelplänen
haben wir gesehen wie offen und dreist
Lobbyarbeit insbesondere bei den Grünen
betrieben wird und auch bei den
ideologieprojekten wie etwa den
Maßnahmen zur Förderung ausgewogener
Ernährung sehen wir Sparpotenzial denn
ehrlich gesagt es ist nicht Aufgabe des
Staates ausgewogene Ernährung zu
predigen zumal ist die Entscheidung
jedes einzelnen ist wie er oder sie sich
ernährt das Geld wäre viel besser
angelegt wenn sie erst einmal die
Grundlagen schaffen würden das
Lebensmittel für jedermann zugänglich
sind so dass die Bürger überhaupt die
Wahl haben statt sie zu bevormunden was
und wie sie zu essen haben da sieht man
dann wieder die typisch grüne Doktrin
Bevormundung über alles das sehen wir
bei der Energie bei der
Gesellschaftspolitik und jetzt soll uns
auch noch vorgegeben werden was wir zu
essen haben
bei dem einen Projekt dass sie sich groß
auf die Fahne geschrieben haben der
Förderung des Umbaus der Tierhaltung
warten wir auch noch immer auf konkretes
dafür haben sie zwar Geld aus dem Gag
genommen das heißt also keinen Cent
extra dafür vorgesehen das sagt ja auch
viel über den Stellenwert den Titel
dreimal hin und hergeschichtet aber was
genau gefördert wird wie zu wann mit
welchen Konditionen da haben die
Landwirte immer noch keine Antworten
ihre Antwort hier wir beraten noch das
ist die typische politantwort wir
beraten noch und werden Sie sich Zeit
nehmen um zu beraten in unsere Landwirte
dank der gestiegenen Energiepreise und
absoluter Unsicherheit für die Zukunft
vor die Hunde
so wie eine zukunftssichere
Landwirtschaft so kann eine
zukunftssichere Landwirtschaft niemals
gelingen lieber Ampel diesen Haushalt
für das Landwirtschaftsministerium
können wir als AFD nicht mittragen es
fehlt vorne und hinten an Substanz und
deshalb sie völlig falschen Prioritäten
legen sie endlich ihre ideologischen
Scheuklappen ab und setzen sie sich für
die wirklichen Bedarfe der Landwirte ein
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
und ist folgt die Berichterstatterin für
die SPD das ist estedicher und wie alle
Berichterstatter ist sie natürlich auch
Mitglied des Haushaltsausschusses
[Applaus]
ja guten Abend sehr geehrter Herr
Präsident sehr geehrter Bundesminister
sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren im
Einzelplan 10 wurden im
Regierungsentwurf wie schon mehrfach
gesagt für 2023 Gesamtausgaben von ca
7,2 Milliarden Euro vorgesehen und Herr
Kollege rief sie sprechen eine ähnliche
Sprache wie unser Minister und ich
vermute mal auch fast denselben Dialekt
aber sie sprechen offensichtlich auch
ein bisschen aneinander vorbei
denn ich denke Einigkeit dürfte bei uns
hier bestehen dass wir die Landwirte
beim Umbau für eine zukunfts-
hatte der Minister im Regierungsentwurf
die 150 Millionen dafür noch in der Gag
eingestellt finden wir das Geld jetzt in
einem Bundesprogramm für den stallumbau
und ich finde es richtig dass wir nicht
nur die Investitionen fördern sondern
uns auch Gedanken darüber machen was ist
denn bedeutet wenn Landwirte zukünftig
Tiere anders halten müssen dass das
nämlich auch Folgekosten und zwar höhere
Folgekosten verursachen wird und dass
wir auch in diesem Bereich dann
unterstützen müssen und das ist gut und
richtig so und nicht so kurz gedacht wie
nur mit einer investitionsanzug
Finanzierung
seitens des Bundes und der EU wird den
Landwirten vorgeschrieben unter welchem
Bedingungen Tiere zu halten sind und da
ist es mehr als gerechtfertigt wenn wir
die Landwirte bei der Umsetzung auch
unterstützen und gerade bei der beim
Titel Gemeinschaftsaufgabe Gaga und
Küstenschutz sind in den vergangenen
Jahren
Millionenbeträge und zwar ein
dreistelliger Höhe nicht abgeflossen und
es gab Länder die die ihnen zugewiesenen
Beträge fast vollständig ausgeben
konnten und andere die keine Projekte
auf den Weg bringen konnten und das
hatte zur Folge dass dann auch der
Bundesanteil von 60% dort überhaupt
nicht zur Auszahlung kam und gerade in
Ländern in denen die Landwirte dann
besondere Unterstützung gebraucht hätten
würde die Förderung oder hängt die
Förderungen davon ab wie stark sich ein
Bundesland in diesem Rahmen engagiert
und das wollen wir gerne verändern
als Bund haben wir ein großes Interesse
daran die Unterstützung auf eine breite
Basis gerade mit allen Bundesländern zu
stellen und wir sind daher gespannt auf
das Konzept welches seitens des
Ministeriums vorgelegt wird und bis
dahin sind die Mittel zunächst gesperrt
die Länder sind aber nach wie vor
herzlich eingeladen sich bei der
Finanzierung des stallumbaus zu
beteiligen
der Union ist dieser Mittelansatz zu
gering wie wir im Ausschuss gehört haben
dort wird gerechnet dass der Umbau von
13 Millionen schweinemastplätze ca 10
Milliarden Euro kosten würde aber es
kann doch nicht wirklich sein dass sie
erwarten dass der Bund tatsächlich die
vollen Kosten übernimmt sondern dass sie
auch nur eine Finanzierung in Form einer
Teilfinanzierung vorsieht
und da sind wir mit einer Milliarde wo
ich davon ausgehe wenn mehr Geld zur
Verfügung steht und das Programm ins
Laufen kommen wir durchaus auch bereit
sind bei einem erfolgreichen Projekt da
auch noch mal den Schwerpunkt
auszureiten
wichtiger als das Geld zu Unterstützung
der Investitionen ist jedoch dass die
entsprechenden Gesetze harmonisiert
werden auch Tarif muss man sagen haben
sie ja schon angesprochen wenn Tiere
nicht nur im Stall gehalten werden
sollen bedarf es unter anderem auch
einer Änderung
emissionsschutzrechtlicher Regelung denn
Tiere im Freien verursachen Emissionen
und deshalb sind zur Zeit beim
stallumbau noch
emissionsschutzrechtliche Grenzwerte
einzuhalten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir befinden uns in der fünften
Jahreszeit aber
solch eine nare Teil kann hier
vermutlich niemand belächeln und das
müssen wir ändern
ein weiterer Knackpunkt im Haushalt für
Ernährung und Landwirtschaft ist die
Ausstattung der Sozialversicherung für
Landwirtschaft Forsten und Gartenbau und
ja wir stehen auch weiterhin dazu dass
die Leistungen für die
Unfallversicherung auf dem vereinbarten
Betrag von 100 Millionen Euro bleiben
und wenn mich vor Ort meine Landwirte
ansprechen und einfordern dass wir diese
Mittel erhöhen möchten dann sage ich gut
dann setzen wir uns aber bitte auch mal
zusammen mit der Sozialversicherung in
einen Tisch und gucken ob die
Hausaufgaben gemacht haben und ihre
Organisationsstrukturen so dargestellt
haben und so aufgebaut haben dass die
Verwaltungskosten runtergefahren werden
und solange das nicht der Fall ist
werden wir hier auch die Kosten die
unseren Beitrag nicht weiter aufstocken
den vermehrt in diesem Haushalt haben
wir auch aus der aus der letzten aus der
letzten Haushalt von 2022 wieder
aufgenommen nämlich für die Beratung und
Betreuung von ArbeitnehmerInnen
insbesondere von amandaarbeiterinnen und
Saisonkräften in Fragen des
Arbeitsschutzes der Arbeitssicherheit
und des Gesundheitsschutzes sind aus
diesem Titel eine Million Euro
vorzusehen viele Betriebe können nämlich
ihre Ernten gar nicht mehr einfahren
ohne Saisonkräfte und daher ist es uns
als Sozialdemokraten besonders wichtig
dass diese Menschen hier vor Ort auch
faire Arbeitsbedingungen vorfinden
Ernährung ist ebenfalls ein großes Thema
in diesem Haushalt und wir fordern
fördern hier ausgewogene Ernährung mit
insgesamt 15,8 Millionen Euro und
Ernährung ist ein wichtiges Thema für
diesen Haushalt das heißt ja schließlich
Landwirtschaft Ernährung Forsten und
Fischerei gehört auch noch dazu und
Ernährung ist ein wichtiges Thema wir
schreiben hier auch niemanden vor Wasser
zu essen hat sondern wir wollen doch nur
darüber aufklären und wenn wir gute
Ernährung fördern können wir
Gesundheitskosten vermeiden also ein
Gewinn für alle
klare Vorgaben haben wir bei der
Beschaffung eines neuen
Forschungsschiffes gemacht ein
Nachfolgebau für die Walter Herbig 3 die
eigentlich nächstes Jahr schon in
Betrieb genommen werden sollte wir
erwarten hier ein modernes
umweltschonendes betriebenes Schiff also
ein Image mit einem emissionsarmen Motor
dass die integrierte Betrachtung des
meeresystem ermöglichen soll das soll
auf dem Verhandlungswege erfolgen
Ausschreibung ist schon gescheitert und
das Schreiben bei dem Ministerium ins
Buch mein Lieblingsthema Wald werden wir
weiter beobachten ob die
Förderrichtlinien jetzt auf dem Weg
gebracht werden und abgerufen wird diese
Haushalt investiert in klimafreundliche
moderne zukunftsfähige Investitionen und
ich freue mich schon drauf auf die
Umsetzung dieses Haushalts vielen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
sagt esta dich ja auch der Wald war hier
ja im Plenum schon häufiger Thema denn
auch dieser ist bedroht wie auch die
vielen Moore die die Koalition besser
schützen möchte Ina Latendorf jetzt für
die Linksfraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kollegen und Kollegen wir sprechen über
Ernährung und Landwirtschaft und gerade
Ernährung betrifft alle Menschen doch
die Bundesregierung nimmt nach wie vor
aus meiner Sicht nicht genügend Mittel
in die Hand für diesen Bereich die
meisten Änderungen zum Vorjahr und zum
ersten Entwurf des Einzelplans des bmwl
sind kosmetische und
verwaltungstechnische Natur und ich
frage sie von der Koalition was denken
Sie wie das bei den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern ankommt die über verteuerte
Lebensmittel spürbare Auswirkungen des
Klimawandels in Naturland Forst und
Fischereiwirtschaft klagen
nicht gut würden Sie sagen und dem
schließe ich mich als Linke an für all
die über 900.000 Menschen die in der
Landwirtschaft arbeiten für 18,7
Millionen Menschen die im ländlichen
Raum leben für alle Menschen die zu
Recht gesunde und bezahlbare
Lebensmittel fordern ist der Haushalt
für Ernährung und Landwirtschaft einfach
ernüchternd die Berichte aus den
landwirtschaftlichen und verarbeitenden
Betrieben deren Zukunft und Existenz auf
der Kippe steht sind verheerend die
Sorgen von Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher über die Preisentwicklung
sind real und erschütternd da ist keine
Luft mehr heute ist der 24 des Monats
und da ist bei vielen Rentnerinnen und
Rentnern bei Alleinerziehenden bei
Menschen mit Minijob das Portemonnaie
leer
und wo bleibt die aktive Umgestaltung
und damit die Sicherung der
Landwirtschaft und der
Nahrungsmittelproduktion mit diesem
Haushalt bleibt sie auf der Strecke
[Applaus]
die
7,175 Milliarden Euro im Etat 23 sind
weniger als zwei Prozent des
Gesamthaushaltes während die
Rüstungsspirale weiterdreht nach Abzug
der im Plan versteckten Sozialleistung
von 3 Milliarden Euro bleiben etwa 0,9%
des Gesamthaushaltes für den Umbau der
Landwirtschaft auf sozialökologische
Standards für Ernährungssicherheit für
Verbraucherschutz für die Entwicklung
der ländlichen Räume für die Fischerei
und für den Wald dass wir eben gehört
haben dessen Umbau so dringend notwendig
ist
ja ich will auch die positiven Dinge
nennen lassen Sie mich drei aufzählen
die betriebsbeihilfe für Fischerei wurde
geschaffen die Hilfe im Zusammenhang mit
dem brexit festgeschrieben und die
Rücknahme der zunächst geplanten
kürzungsversuche bei den Bundesmitteln
der Welt ernährungsorganisation FAU war
dringend fällig und ist richtig aber was
fehlt
eine vernünftige Politik die der
jetzigen Preistreiberei Einhalt gebietet
schon lange wären wirksame Maßnahmen
gegen Ernährung
Nahrungsmittelspekulation und
Preisexplosion notwendig gewesen und
hier und Tätigkeit werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Fraktion DIE LINKE
unternimmt in jedem Haushaltsjahr die
den Versuch die zentrale eine
zentralforderung für soziale
Gerechtigkeit umzusetzen und dabei geht
es um das Bundesprogramm Kita und
Schulverpflegung in der Höhe von 2
Milliarden Euro sie haben morgen noch
einmal die Chance unserem
entschließungantrag dafür zuzustimmen
und ihr sie mir wieder mit Länder
Zuständigkeiten kommen schauen sie ins
Grundgesetz nach Artikel 104 B und C
Grundgesetz ist das auch möglich Schul-
und kitaverpflegung ist sozial Umwelt
Ernährung und Gesundheitspolitik
gleichermaßen Schulen und Kitas sind
Orte wo alle Kinder und Jugendliche
gleichermaßen erreicht werden können
Bund und Länder müssen hier an einem
Strang ziehen und das bislang übliche
ressort-denken nicht nur zwischen den
Ministerien sondern auch zwischen Bund
und Ländern muss endlich aufhören
wir folgen mit unserer Forderung den
wissenschaftlichen wissenschaftlichen
Beirat für
agrar-politik Ernährung und
gesundheitlichen Verbraucherschutz des
bmi-l die zentrale Empfehlung lautet
eine beitragsfreie qualitativ
hochwertige Kita und Schulverpflegung
schrittweise in ganz Deutschland zu
etablieren um eine gesunde Ernährung
gerade für die Jugendlichen zu erreichen
und die soziale Komponente ist dabei
nicht zu vergessen bedenken Sie die
aktuelle Situation die Inflation bei
Lebensmitteln und Energie verteuert das
Angebot in den Schulen erheblich Eltern
melden ihre Kinder von der
Schulverpflegung ab die Kinder essen
dann ihr mitgebrachtes Brot oder im
schlimmsten Fall nichts während andere
eine warme Mahlzeit bekommen die dadurch
erlebte Diskriminierung können sie sich
wohl ausmalen
ich habe die Bundesregierung zu diesem
Thema befragt zur ernährungsarmut die
Antwort war bei einem informierten
preisbewussten Einkauf könne man
heutzutage mit 5,09 Euro pro Person am
Tag eine gesund erhaltene Ernährung
ermöglichen wo leben sie eigentlich das
ist eins darum
sie haben die vollmundig angekündigte
Agrarwende gerade untergepflügt die
gesunde Ernährung ist in irgendeiner
Schublade versenkt worden und die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher stehen
im Regen das können wir nicht durchgehen
lassen
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
Frank Scheffler ist nun der nächste
Redner er sitzt für die FDP-Fraktion im
Haushaltsausschuss
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine lieben Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die Ernährungsfrage ist die
große Frage unserer Zeit
sie war es aber schon immer
robert maltus hat im Ende des 18
Jahrhunderts gesagt die Bevölkerung hat
die dauerhafte Neigung sich über das Maß
der vorhandenen Nahrungsmittel zu
vermehren
heute wissen wir das war ein Fehlschluss
er hat sich geirrt die Weltbevölkerung
steigt zwar 1800 betrug die
Weltbevölkerung eine Milliarde heute
sind es 8 Milliarden und im Jahre 2050
sind es zehn Milliarden
neue Anbaumethoden der technische
Fortschritt
Düngemittel
verändertes Saatgut haben dazu
beigetragen ja dass sie Hungernden auf
dieser Welt
massiv zurückgegangen sind im 18
Jahrhundert waren 90 Prozent der
Bevölkerung hungernde
1980 waren es noch 20 Prozent und heute
sind es immer noch zehn Prozent aber bei
einer wachsenden Bevölkerung
erstaunlicherweise wesentlich weniger
und der Grund ist
dass zwischen 1961 und 2009 die
wirtschaftlich genutzte Fläche zwar um
12% zu nahmen aber die Produktivität in
der Landwirtschaft und 300% zugenommen
hat
in 150 Jahren hat sich die Produktivität
zum Beispiel beim Ernten von Weizen um
sage und schreibe
2500 fache erhöht
Landwirte ich sage dass deshalb damit
deutlich wird das Landwirte Unternehmer
sind die nicht nur regional unterwegs
sind sondern Landwirte produzieren
Lebensmittel für den Weltmarkt
und deshalb ist es notwendig dass wir
die Wettbewerbsbedingungen für die
Landwirtschaft in Deutschland und die
Standardbedingungen der Landwirtschaft
in Deutschland im internationalen
Wettbewerb betrachten und sie dafür fit
machen und dafür haben wir als FDP in
diesen Haushaltsberatungen
[Musik]
wichtige Weichen gestellt zum Beispiel
haben wir dafür gesorgt dass 3 Millionen
für Forschung in vertical farming also
in neue Anbau Methoden gesteckt werden
können und wir haben dafür gesorgt und
das ist mir auch sehr wichtig dass wir
mit 8 Millionen Euro zusätzlich für die
Genforschung Mittel bereitgestellt haben
denn gehen Forschung ist nicht nur
Risiko sondern es ist eine große Chance
für die weltanährung auf dieser in der
heutigen Zeit und wir haben deutlich
gemacht dass wir auch die
Digitalisierung in der Landwirtschaft
stärken wollen letztendlich geht es
immer um die Frage wie kann man die
Wettbewerbsbedingungen der deutschen
Landwirtschaft insgesamt verbessern und
da ist es notwendig finde ich dass wir
die Landwirtschaft auch dem Wettbewerb
aussetzen
und deshalb bin ich sehr froh dass wir
in der Koalition vereinbart haben dass
wir das Freihandelsabkommen ceta auch im
Deutschen Bundestag endlich ratifizieren
wollen ich weiß die Landwirtschaft ist
in vielen Bereichen dort ausgenommen
aber sein erster Schritt und wir müssen
weitergehen wir müssen auch ttip wieder
mit neuem mit neuer neu entfachen und
neue initiieren mit den Amerikanern
zusammen ich glaube das ist wichtig um
letztendlich die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
der deutschen Landwirtschaft auch wieder
zu stärken
ich will das vielleicht mit Friedrich
August von Hayek in dem Sinne darlegen
der hat gesagt ist die Hauptaufgabe des
Wettbewerbes zu zeigen welche Pläne
falsch sind und das ist glaube ich auch
notwendig damit Geschäftsmodelle auch im
Wettbewerb überprüft werden und das ist
glaube ich die eigentlich die Essenz des
Wettbewerbes dass sie deutlich macht was
funktioniert und was funktioniert nicht
und wenn wir die Landwirtschaft
einbetten wenn wir sie pudern wenn wir
sie mit Subventionen wie ist die Union
will ständig vom Markt fernhalten dann
führt das letztendlich dazu ja dass die
Bedingungen für die Landwirtschaft nicht
besser werden sondern dann werden
irgendwann tatsächlich die
Marktbedingungen so schlecht dass wir
einen Weltmarkt nicht mehr Bestand haben
werden und deshalb ist es notwendig dass
wir den Wettbewerb aktiv suchen auch
international aktiv suchen und uns nicht
verstecken
wenn wir das machen wenn wir die
Rahmenbedingungen verbessern für die
deutsche Landwirtschaft dann ist mehr um
die Landwirte in diesem Land nicht bange
sondern ich glaube sie lächzen
letztendlich danach dass sie nicht
ständig mit neuen subventionsprogrammen
beglückt werden sondern tatsächlich
Rahmenbedingungen haben die sie am Ende
als Unternehmer kenntlich machen und Sie
als Unternehmer auch am Markt agieren
lassen vielen Dank
Frank Schaeffler war das für die
FDP-Fraktion und nun folgt Albert
Stegemann erst der Sprecher für
Ernährung und Landwirtschaft der
Unionsfraktion hier in der Debatte zum
Einzelplan 10 Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen
ja schlecht informierten Kreisen hört
man immer wieder Haushaltsreden sind
langweilig trockene Zahlen ich kann
Ihnen sagen ich empfinde das ganz anders
weil Haushaltsreden ehrlich sind weil
man wirklich an Haushaltsreden erkennen
kann wie eine Regierung wie Parteien wie
Fraktion wie sie tatsächlich zu Themen
stehen und wie sie auch Themen
priorisieren so und jetzt mit Blick auf
den jetzigen Haushalt kann man erstmal
sagen ja ist vielleicht auch ein
bisschen langweilig sind 2% aufwuchs
klar bei 10,4 % Inflation hätte man
sagen können hätte auch ein bisschen
mehr sein können wenn man ein bisschen
genauer hinschaut dann sieht man
Verwaltungsaufgaben sind erheblich
gestiegen die Leistung für Landwirte
sind geschrumpft aber auch das an der
Stelle der will wollen wir gar nicht
kleinkariert sein das könnte man alles
kritisieren sondern es gibt ein paar
Dinge die gar nicht wesentlich auffallen
die uns aber wirklich viel viel schwerer
bereiten und zwar ich komme auch auf die
Unterstützung und auf den Umbau der
Tierhaltung zu sprechen haben wir einige
Kollegen auch schon stolz wie Bolle hier
vorgetragen Mensch 150 Millionen das ist
doch jetzt mal ein Anfang und da wende
ich mich jetzt auch mal an sie hier als
sie mir sie haben diese 150 Milliarden
auch immer wieder in Schaufenster
gestellt und wir seit Jahren haben wir
immer wieder diskutiert in der zkl in
Borchert wir mit borcher zusammen mit
dem Kompetenznetzwerk nutzt die Haltung
und dort gibt es wissenschaftliche
Berechnungen dass wir für einen
ehrlichen Umbau der Tierhaltung
mindestens 4 Milliarden Euro im Jahr
brauchen und diese Zahlen stammen vor
der Teuerungsrate vor den Teuerungen
durch Inflation vor allen Dingen eine
überproportionale Inflation am Bau das
heißt wenn wir ehrlich ein Umbau der
Tierhaltung organisieren wollen dann
können wir uns inzwischen auf Kosten von
6 bis 8 Milliarden Euro einstellen und
sie kommen dann hier mit 150 Millionen
Euro
diese Summe ist lächerlich absolut
lächerlich ich glaube sie haben auch und
das ich lehnen das persönlich gar nicht
übel aber ich glaube sie wissen einfach
nicht was auf den landwirtschaftlichen
Betrieben los ist wir haben wir reden
immer wieder ja hier ebener bitte sie
reden auch immer über
ressourcenschonendes handeln aber eine
Ressource machen wir zurzeit kaputt und
das ist die Zuversicht bei jungen
Landwirten haben sie sich mal in den
letzten Jahren mit jungen Landwirten
unterhalten wissen wie wissen Sie was
auf den Höfen los ist es gibt keine
Möglichkeit zu investieren keine sie
bekommen keine Baugenehmigung sie haben
baurechtliche Probleme
emissionsrechtliche Probleme dann gibt
es Probleme bei der Markteinschätzung
dann gibt es eine eine fehlende
Akzeptanz der Gesellschaft und der
Politik und sie kommen hier mit 150
Millionen also wirklich das ist ein
absoluter treppensitz und das kann ich
leider nicht anders nennen und ich kann
Ihnen das auch nicht ersparen jetzt
kommen sie mit ihrer Milliarde ja bitte
schön eine Milliarde über drei vier
Jahres verteilt entschuldigung das lasse
ich ihm nicht durchgehen und dass sie
sich in der Ampel nicht einig werden das
ist das Problem der Ampel und das ist
das Problem der Fraktion aber wir als
Opposition bewerten die Arbeit der
Bundesregierung und die hat hier einfach
nicht stattgefunden und das bitte ich
dann auch mal zu aktivieren
zuzuhören und nicht so ich habe gerade
einfach nur darum bitten aber die
Mitglieder der Fraktion Bündnis 19 grün
und nicht so verstärkt dazwischen
wunderbar aber ich freue mich natürlich
wenn es äh doch hier wahrgenommen wird
was man hier spricht und Reaktion
hervorhebt aber stattdessen wenn wir uns
dann anschauen was geht dann an
Schaufenster Politik wirklich gemacht
habe das heute der Presse entnommen da
geht jetzt eine viertel Millionen für
eine neue tierschutzstelle ausgegeben
das ist wirklich schaufensterpolitik da
hilft man hier vielleicht einem alten
grünen Parteifreund das ist eine B6
Stelle die ist hoch dotiert dann gibt's
noch garniert ist das ganze noch mit
zwei A 13 Stellen also da macht man dann
wirklich hier wirklich da macht man
reine schaufensterpolitik aber da wo sie
hätten wirklich was tun können weil
durch hat da war man schon so weit davor
sagen sie und das ist absolut nicht in
Ordnung
dann will ich Ihnen noch etwas sagen was
jetzt nicht direkt im Einzelplan ziehen
steht aber was wir auch dringend hier
mal besprechen sollten das ist die
übergewinnbesteuerung bei dem
Biogasanlagen wir waren gestern fast mit
der kompletten Truppe die jetzt hier
sitzt von der Union wir waren bei der
Demonstration wir haben uns die Sorgen
angehört und es gibt ja jetzt auch ein
bisschen Bewegung in der Sache aber das
weiß glaube ich auch jeder hier im Haus
hinter vorgehaltener Hand
erzählen Haushaltspolitiker der Union
die das am Ende auch mit habe ich ein
Stückchen weitaus gehandelt haben also
deswegen auch noch mal Danke an unseren
haushaltsstoffe der hat da wirklich eine
gute Vorarbeit geleistet natürlich geht
das ganze nicht weit genug wenn wir
jetzt wirklich hier die Bagatellgrenze
bei
[Musik]
bei einem Megawatt belassen dann reicht
das nicht aus dann sind die Anlagen
diskriminiert die jetzt wirklich auf
Flexibilisierung gesetzt haben die
investiert haben die genau das getan
haben was sie von ihnen wollten nämlich
dann Strom zu liefern und abzuliefern
wenn das Netz ist braucht diese Anlagen
werden jetzt nicht im Gewinn abgeschöpft
sondern im Erlös abgeschöpft und das ist
einfach der große Unterschied zwischen
Gewinn und Umsatz ist ja häufig wird das
durcheinander gebracht also da
appelliere ich noch mal da sollen sie an
der Stelle sollten Sie auch Anwalt der
Landwirt der Landwirte sein der zu mir
in ihre antriebsrede haben Sie gesagt
Sie sind sie wollen Anwalt der Landwirte
sein das waren jetzt vielleicht nur
kleine Beispiele aber sie haben gezeigt
dass sie bislang allenfalls maximal ein
Pflichtverteidiger sind und deswegen
fordere ich Sie auch von hier aus fangen
Sie an Ihre Arbeit aufzunehmen werden
sie zum Anwalt der Landwirte und kümmern
Sie sich endlich um die Interessen der
Landwirte die warten darauf und dazu
wollen wir sie motivieren vielen Dank
eine Milliarde Euro ist zu wenig für den
Umbau der Tierhaltung sagt Albert
Stegemann und eigentlich ist er da gar
nicht so weit entfernt vom
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister Cem
Özdemir der hat nämlich genau das
gleiche gesagt das können nur einen
Anfang sein
genaueres kann er jetzt selber sagen
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen meine Herren diese
Haushalt steht für eine Politik die
klimaböden Arten schützt und zugleich
dem Erhalt der Höfe dient er steht für
die Sicherung unserer Ernährung bei uns
und überall auf der Welt er gibt den
Bäuerinnen und Bauern endlich
Planungssicherheit und Perspektive ich
danke den Haushälterinnen und
Haushältern ausdrücklich dass Sie unsere
Politik den Weg Ebenen und mit ihren
Beschlüssen sogar noch verstärken die
Landwirte
die Landwirte nun Landwirte wollen
Verbraucherin Verbrauchern Klima und
Tieren gerecht werden jetzt kommt es
allerdings auch auf die Politik an diese
Veränderungsbereitschaft die längst da
ist auch tatkräftig zu unterstützen und
genau das tun wir indem wir die
Grundlagen für ein Bundesprogramm zum
Umbau der Tierhaltung endlich schaffen
zum fast eine Milliarde Euro als
Anschubfinanzierung bei der
Schweinehaltung damit sollen
Investitionen in den Umbau hin zu
tiergerechten Stellen gefördert werden
aber eben nicht nur das denn wir wollen
die Tierhalter auch bei den laufenden
Mehrkosten für mehr Tierwohl
unterstützen wir geben unseren
Landwirtinnen und Landwirten jetzt auch
die finanzielle Planungssicherheit für
mehr Tierschutz deshalb streben wir für
die Unterstützung bei den laufenden
Mehrkosten Verträge mit einer Laufzeit
von bis zu zehn Jahren mit Hochdruck
arbeiten wir nun an den Eckpunkten des
Bundesprogramms und den Kriterien der
Förderung
ich kann mir vorstellen und so ein
bisschen beim Zuhören habe ich mir das
gedacht dass bei einigen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Union die innerliche
Zerrissenheit groß sein muss man sieht
sie ja auch an da wird jetzt endlich der
zukunftsfeste umbaute Tierhaltung in
Deutschland angepackt und dann muss es
ausgerechnet die Ampel sein und dann
auch noch ein grüner Minister und auch
noch ein Vegetarier den Mittel dafür
organisiert
das ist hat sich weiß das ist hat
diese Regierung bringt ja nicht nur ein
haltungskennzeichen auf dem Weg sondern
wir machen in Brüssel auch Druck für
eine herkunftskennzeichen dass uns für
Anfang des Jahres zugesagt ist Tarif
wenn man schwäbisch schwätz fällt mir
immer schwer zurückzukommen aber jetzt
muss ich ihn doch mal sagen wir halten
das was sie 16 Jahre versprochen haben
meine Damen meine Herren
wir ändern das Baurecht damit die Bauern
des überhaupt tun können wir packen die
TA-Luft an wir machen eine Milliarde
Anschubfinanzierung bei den Schweinen
und da geht es weiter mit den anderen
Nutztieren wir haben vom LH die Zusage
dass bei stahlplusplatz die
Weiterfinanzierung gesichert ist und ich
habe gerade noch gesagt auf diejenigen
die zu Recht sagen was es mit
ausländischen Fleisch kommt jetzt
endlich die herkunftskennzeichen das
hätten sie in 16 Jahren nicht geschafft
was sie in ungefähr einem Jahr macht
meine Damen meine Herren
mit diesem Haushalt stärken wir aber
auch unsere internationales Engagement
und der prekären Ernährungslage der Welt
zu begegnen gestatten bilaterale
kooperationsprogramme mit zusätzlichem
Geld aus diese Programme leistenden
wichtigen Beitrag zu globalen Ernährung
auch im Kontext des russischen
angriffskriegs auf die Ukraine
beispielsweise durch Unterstützung des
Welt Ernährungsprogramms damit das
fundamentale Recht auf Nahrung endlich
gesichert wird unser Haushalt leistet
auch ein Beitrag zum Klimaschutz unsere
Wälder gehören zu den besten
Klimaanlagen die man sich vorstellen
kann deshalb investieren wir 900
Millionen Euro in Ihre Zukunft Geld des
bitter notwendig ist ich habe sehr schon
vergangenen Wochenende im
Naturschutzgebiet
Rotwildpark in Stuttgart bei der
Begehung mit försterinnen und Förster
normal gesehen übrigens auch eine gute
Gelegenheit ist das Hohe Haus den
försterinnen und Förstern aber auch den
waldbäuerinnen und Bauern ihre
großartige Arbeit für unseren Wald finde
es wirklich toll und beeindruckend wenn
man mit denen spricht wenn man die fragt
wie sieht denn der Wald in 30 40 Jahren
aus da blickt man sorgenvolle Minen
angesichts der Klimakrise aber ein Stich
vertaucht dabei immer auf Vielfalt jetzt
müssen sie hat im Glauben sein die
Kollegen von der AFD auch der deutsche
Wald damit der Zukunft hat braucht
Vielfalt auch das setzt diese Koalition
um meine Damen meine Herren mit diesem
Haushalt stärken wir auch die ländlichen
Räume damit unsere Demokratie und unsere
Wirtschaft auch dort Zukunft haben wir
bestehen wir bauen die bestehenden
Förderprogramme wie das Bundesprogramm
ländliche Entwicklung aus nur gemeinsam
gelingt zu uns heute noch
strukturschwache Region zu beleben den
Menschen dort Perspektiven zu schaffen
den Zusammenhalt zu stärken diese
Regierung ist auf dem Weg
Ernährung und Landwirtschaft
nachhaltiger ökologische zu gestalten
damit ländliche Räume eine lebenswerte
Zukunft haben ich danke Ihnen
der Bundesminister für Ernährung und der
Landwirtschaft hat hier in seiner Rede
noch einmal seine Politik verteidigt
nächster Redner ist Bernd Schattner für
die afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
Herr Minister es ist festzuhalten dass
offensichtlich bei dem heute hier
vorliegenden Haushalt wieder einmal
ökologisten klimakleber und sonstige
Ideologen ohne Sachverstand in tuneIn
angegeben haben
die Nöte und Sorgen der Landwirte wurden
augenscheinlich dabei nicht
berücksichtigt das ist aber auch kein
Wunder denn im agrarmministerium wurden
keine Landwirte mit Sachverstand mehr
eingestellt sondern seit September
wurden alleine acht Mitarbeiter aus den
Verbänden BND Bioland deutscher
Naturschutzring bühlw Deutsche
Umwelthilfe und der Welthungerhilfe mit
Versorgungsposten bedacht und damit die
Klima und Tierschutz Extremisten auch
von öffentlichen Steuergeldern
profitieren sind alleine seit dem
Amtsantritt von Herrn Minister Özdemir
40 Millionen mehr an Verbände die
Bioland die meta- oder Peter im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr geflossen
das zeigt dass die Grünen nicht nur die
Tierhaltung sondern am liebsten die
komplette konventionelle Landwirtschaft
abschaffen wollen
statt über Tierhaltung diskutieren wir
ja nur noch über die
CO2-Emissionen der Tiere an das Wohl der
Tiere und unserer Landwirte denkt da
schon lange niemand mehr das Hilfe
sterben ist für die Grünen aber offenbar
das einfachste Rezept für mehr
Klimaschutz in der Landwirtschaft das
beste Beispiel ist hier die
borchert-kommission ja schon mehrfach
angesprochen wurde von der vollmund
nicht angekündigten Milliarde für den
stallumbau aus dem jetzt sowieso nur
noch 600 Millionen Euro übrig wenn man
die Verwaltungskosten runterrechnet und
der Ansatz von 150 Millionen für das
Jahr 2023 wird jetzt nicht freigegeben
da ist noch kein Plan gibt aber mit
keinem Plan kennt sich der Herr Minister
ja scheinbar bestens aus mehr als
Hanfanbau auf der Dachterrasse kommt das
selten von ihm
egal ob doppelwumms für 200 Milliarden
hier oder 100 Milliarden sonderschulden
Bundeswehr da für alles hat die
Bundesregierung Geld nur unsere
Bäuerinnen und Bauern gehen mal wieder
leer aus
die Realeinkommen unserer Landwirte sind
schon zu Zeiten der CDU gesunken und der
ihrer Koalition geht es jetzt noch
deutlich schneller bergab
Schlachtunternehmen können den
Landwirten nicht nur das Geld zahlen
dass diese angesichts der steigenden
Kosten bräuchten viele Tierhalter stehen
kurz vor der Insolvenz und sehen keine
Perspektive mehr in Deutschland allein
zehn Prozent weniger Schweineproduktion
innerhalb eines Jahres zeigt uns den Weg
auf wohin wir uns bewegen meine Damen
und Herren die Selbstversorgung mit
Fleisch aus Deutschland ist in Gefahr
Westfleisch Vertriebsleiter und VDF
Vorstand Hubertus kelliger sagte auf der
EuroTier wir sind jetzt an einem Punkt
der wir uns ausrechnen können wann wir
uns nicht mehr selbst versorgen können
Fleisch zu einem knappen Gut wird und
die Regale in den Supermärkten nicht
mehr mit in Deutschland produzierten
fleischertiteln gefüllt sind aber genau
das will diese Regierung ja offenbar
weder Hilfe für den Einkauf von
Mineraldünger noch eine Verdoppelung der
Agrar die diese rückstattung wie von der
AFD gefordert sind für diese
Bundesregierung wichtig die all diese
Rückerstattung wird hierbei als
klimaschädliches Subventionen von den
Grünen aber auch genauso von der
einst-konservativen Union bezeichnet und
beim Mineraldünger sollen die deutschen
Bauern dann sparen gleichzeitig aber
weniger viel halten und die Flächen dann
mit organischen Dünger besser zu
versorgen den es ohne Tierhaltung aber
gar nicht mehr geben kann
meine Damen und Herren an diesen
Entwicklungen lässt sich ganz klar
erkennen ein grüner
Landwirtschaftsminister schadet der
Landwirtschaft in Deutschland massiv
aber wie mittlerweile merkt die
lebensversorgung nicht mehr
selbstverständlich ist und die
Verteuerung der Lebensmittel spürbaren
spüren nicht nur die armenbürger
inzwischen gibt es in Deutschland 962
Tafeln seit Beginn des ukrainekrieges
verzeichnen rund 61 Prozent der Tafeln
einen Zuwachs ihrer Kunden und bis zu
50%. und 30% der Tafeln haben bis zu
doppelt so viele Kunden und 9% haben
mehr als doppelt so viele Kunden hierzu
findet sich leider im aktuellen
Haushaltsplan gar nichts statt die
Ärmsten der Gesellschaft gezielt zu
unterstützen trägt dieser Haushalt klar
den Stempel der klimaetologie sieht
soziale Politik aus wir von der AFD
sagen da ganz klar nein deutsche
Steuergeld muss endlich wieder für die
deutschen Interessen verwendet werden
bezahlbare Lebensmittel durch die
Streichung der Mehrwertsteuer wäre nur
ein Beispiel was schon lange gefordert
haben
weitere drei Jahre grüne
Landwirtschaftspolitik kann sich dieses
Land nicht leisten sonst sind wir wieder
im Mittelalter mit Flug und Ochsen kann
das meine Damen und Herren wird es mit
uns von der AFD nicht geben vielen Dank
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich grüße
Sie alle zur Spätschicht die ist heute
halbwegs noch im Rahmen und sie bleibt
das auch wenn sie sich alle natürlich an
ihre Redezeiten halten wir haben ja noch
ein Einzelplan aber jetzt erhält erstmal
das Wort dr Matthias Mirsch für die
SPD-Fraktion und Matthias Mörsch ist
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen vor wenigen Wochen hat die
wichtigste Stiftung in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland die Deutsche
Bundesstiftung Umwelt zwei jungen Frauen
ein Ehrenpreis verliehen nämlich
Miriam rapior die frühere Bund
jugendvorsitzende und Katrin muß als
Vertreterin der Bund des Bundes
Deutscher Landjugend diese beiden jungen
Frauen haben aus meiner Sicht das
geschafft was eigentlich der Schlüssel
für unsere zukünftige Landwirtschaft
Politik sein muss nämlich über die
Gräben hinweg gemeinsam Dinge zu
formulieren in der Zukunftskommission
Landwirtschaft wo Landwirtschaft nicht
gegen Ökologie und gegen Ökonomie
gedacht wird sondern zusammen für die
Sozialdemokratie kann ich sagen das ist
unser Bild von Landwirtschaft es geht
nur miteinander und nicht gegeneinander
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und lieber Herr rief wenn sie dem
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister Talkshow
Auftritte vorwerfen da muss ich Ihnen
schon sagen das was sich die letzten
vier Jahre mit einer
Bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin Julia
Klöckner erlebt habe war leider nicht
nur Talkshow sondern auch ganz viel
Hochglanz ohne irgendeine Inhalt drin
und insofern bin ich froh dass dieser
Landwirtschaftsminister nun liefert
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja Herr Stegemann und wenn sie jetzt
sagen ist ja lächerlich das was Sie
gesagt haben fand ich ehrlicherweise
auch etwas lächerlich wenn Sie hier uns
vorwerfen wir wüssten nicht wie es auf
Höfen in Deutschland aussieht ich will
Ihnen mal ich will Ihnen mal sagen ich
habe die Zweifel sie wissen es
vielleicht aber wer die Hofstruktur der
Landwirte Politikerin der letzten Jahre
der Union sich mal anguckt kann schon
die Frage sich stellen für welche Art
von Landwirtschaft eigentlich hier
Politik und Lobbyismus gemacht worden
ist
und deswegen ich bin froh dass es hier
jetzt etwas gelingt was wir vier Jahre
in der großen Koalition nicht geschafft
haben endlich schaffen wir im Bereich
des tierwohls ein verbindliches Tier wo
Label was natürlich flankiert werden
muss auch mit einer entsprechenden
Finanzierung mit baurechtlichen
Anpassungen und mit den
Grundvoraussetzungen das Landwirte
tatsächlich in mehr Tierwohl investieren
können liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und deswegen nein sie wir haben es nicht
verhindert Herr Stegemann ihre
Ministerin war nicht mal in der Lage
Grundlagen dafür vorzulegen wir werden
jetzt noch im Dezember hier die
Grundlagen diskutieren und dann in
diesem Parlament eine verbindliche
Kennzeichnung einschließlich der
Finanzierung beschließen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja das können sie können Sie gerne
beobachten sie können sich sogar
konstruktiv auch mit einbringen sie sind
herzlich eingeladen wir nehmen auch
gerne Anregungen weiter mit auf ich will
aber neben dem Tier Aspekt einen anderen
Aspekt ganz bewusst hier auch ansprechen
der ein bisschen Rand und Nischenthema
hat wir leben gerade in diesen Tagen und
in diesen Wochen das Leben Energie
Wasser Ernährung der zentrale
Bestandteil unseres Zusammenlebens ist
gestern haben liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hier in Berlin viele Menschen
demonstriert gegen die weitere
Patentierung von Pflanzen und Lebewesen
das ist ein Thema ein Nischenthema aber
ich sage es ganz bewusst es ist richtig
auch Gelder für Genforschung hier
einzustellen und sich sehr genau mit
gefahren und auch möglicherweise mit
Chancen zu beschäftigen
aber ich sage ganz bewusst wer das tut
muss gleichzeitig auch die Strategie von
großen Konzernen der letzten Jahrzehnte
im Blick haben was teilweise mit neuen
Züchtungsmethoden passiert ist wenn wir
ähnlich wie wir es im Energiesektor
viele viele Jahrzehnte hatten auch im
Bereich der Ernährung eine Konzentration
des Saatguts auf weniger haben dann
haben wir Abhängigkeiten die genau die
Vielfalt der Landwirtschaft einschränken
sowohl international wie national das
dürfen wir nicht zulassen und deswegen
müssen wir diese Entwicklung ganz genau
im Blick haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Präsident der jetzt gerade mit der
wertenpräsidentin gewechselt hat hat
eben von Genuss und Landwirtschaft
gesprochen ja da hat er recht aber wir
sehen auch Landwirtschaft der Zukunft
ist die Schlüsselfrage auch dieser
Gesellschaft insofern bedanke ich mich
bei allen die im ersten Jahr an dieser
Landwirtschaftspolitik der Ampel
mitgemacht haben wir haben noch eine
Menge vor uns ich bin sicher wir werden
noch die nächsten drei Jahre Großes
bewegen können vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
der Dank von Matthias Müller Stifte auch
den nächsten an den nächsten Redner
gerichtet sein Gero Hocker ist nämlich
der landwirtschaftspolitische Sprecher
der FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
verehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Landwirtschaft in Deutschland vor allem
die tierhaltenden Betriebe befinden sich
in der wohl größten Krise der
vergangenen 70 Jahre und zwar nicht weil
sie etwa schlechte Produkte erzeugen
würden
und auch nicht weil sie ineffizient
wären
und auch nicht weil sie
nicht gut ausgebildetes Personal zur
Verfügung hätten ganz im Gegenteil meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren der
zentrale Punkt für die Krise die wir
gegenwärtig sehen müssen liegt in dem
Umstand es in den letzten 16 Jahren und
übrigens auch darüber hinaus immer
häufiger
nationalstaatlicher Alleingänge
beschritten wurden und so die
Produktionsstandards immer weiter
auseinandergegangen sind meine sehr
verehren und das ist der Grund
das ist der Grund dafür dass der
Wettbewerb zwischen inländischen
Erzeuger und ausländischen Erzeuger
schon lange nicht mehr nach fairen
Kriterien erfolgt dieser unfaire
Wettbewerb ist es der Betriebsinhabern
das Leben in Deutschland so schwer macht
immer mehr Betriebe in den letzten
Jahren und Jahrzehnten in den Ruinen
getrieben hat und dieser unfaire
Wettbewerb der ist es der am Ende dazu
führt das Lebensmittel in Deutschland
auf dem Teller des Verbrauchers landen
die aus dem Ausland nach Deutschland
kommen und zu Standards erzeugt wurden
die man einem deutschen Landwirt niemals
zugestanden hätte meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren und dieser Entwicklung
muss endlich etwas entgegengesetzt
werden und es ist zentrale Aufgabe
dieser Bundesregierung und der sie
tragen Fraktion das endlich zu tun
und meine werden Kollegen und Kollegen
der Union so oft ist Landwirtschaft in
den letzten Jahrzehnten ich beschränk's
ausdrücklich nicht auf 16 Jahre in den
letzten Jahrzehnten sind falsche
Versprechungen gemacht worden wurde Geld
ins Schaufenster gestellt wurde
angereizt dass man vielleicht auch
wieder eigene Mittel investiert dass man
zur Bank geht und neuerliche zusätzliche
Kredite aufnimmt sich verschuldet neue
Geschäftsmodelle entwickelt das Problem
war das häufig genug die
Geschäftsmodelle die Politik sich
gewünscht hat vom Erzeuger vom
Verbraucher eben überhaupt nicht
honoriert wurden das ist das Problem und
ich sage Ihnen eins wer diese
Fehlentwicklung der vergangenen Jahre
und Jahrzehnte Fortschritt und glaubt
sie alleine kompensieren zu können
dadurch dass man wiederum Geld ins
Schaufenster stellt der versündigt sich
an einer ganzen Branche und der führt
die Fehler fort die sie in den letzten
Jahrzehnten zu verantworten haben und da
machen wir nicht mit Kollegen
ich sage Ihnen eins lieber Albert
Stegemann und statt wiederum Landwirte
mit falschen Versprechungen in neue
Abenteuer zu locken muss
Landwirtschaftspolitik im Jahre 2023 ein
neues Kapitel aufschlagen wir müssen
Dreier tun erstens wir müssen denjenigen
betrieben die gerne bereit sind zu
investieren vielleicht sogar aus eigenen
Mitteln endlich die Gewähr geben dass
wenn sie investieren aus eigenen oder
auch aus fremdkapitalmitteln das nicht
nach drei oder nach fünf oder nach zwölf
oder nach 24 Monaten wiederum neuerliche
Auflagen über ihnen ausgeschüttet werden
egal ob aus Berlin ob aus Hannover oder
aus einer Landesregierung oder von der
kommunalen Ebene der Vergangenheit das
ist unsere Aufgabe denn sonst wird kein
Investment erfolgen sonst würde es nicht
gelingen das zusätzlich in noch mehr
Tierwohl in Deutschland investiert
werden wir brauchen endlich einen
Auflagen Moderator Abgeordneter erlauben
sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
afd-fraktion ja
ins Eingemachte gehen
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin danke
Herr Kollege dass sie diese Frage
zulassen sie haben ja eben ich sag mal
sehr intensiv auf die CDU und die
letzten 16 Jahre eingedroschen und
darüber das unterschiedliche Standards
geschaffen wurden nun ist meine Frage
oder das worum es mir geht am Dienstag
hatten wir eine Sondersitzung im
Ausschuss für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft da ging es um die
Ordnung bzw das Gesetz für die
Tierarzneimittel wo in vorher in der
Anhörung jeder Experte gesagt hat das
ist zu scharf das ist zu doll das geht
so nicht wo sie ja nun gerade gesagt
haben wir dürfen in diesem Land keine
Alleingänge machen keine besonderen
Standard schaffen und sie ist der CDU
vorgeworfen haben nun frage ich sie wie
heuchlerisch kann man sein genau
dasselbe zu betreiben und hier etwas
anderes zu behaupten
die Frage von Frank Rink aus der
afd-fraktion lässt ist unsere
Geschäftsordnung nicht zu dass auf eine
Frage mit einer Gegenfrage geantwortet
wird aber ich sage Ihnen ganz
ausdrücklich es muss das Ziel dieser
Bundesregierung und der sie tragenden
Fraktionen sein zu verhindern dass der
nationalstaatlicher allein gegen
beschritten werden und am vergangenen
Dienstag haben wir eine Sondersitzung
des Landwirtschaftsausschuss gehabt weil
wir uns sehr intensiv genommen mit der
Frage beschäftigt haben wie man das
hinbekommt abzuwägen zwischen dem was
notwendig ist und dem was zusätzliche
Auflagen bedeuten würde und ich glaube
dass diese Koalition insgesamt ein sehr
guten Kompromiss gefunden hat deswegen
passt ihre Frage überhaupt nicht zu dem
was ich eben gesagt habe
[Applaus]
Herr Rink ich erteilen ein Ordnungsruf
fertig liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der zweite Punkt ist dass der
Verbraucher und da ist die Koalition
tatsächlich auf einem guten gemeinsamen
Weg dass der Verbraucher endlich
tatsächlich transparent und
unkompliziert erkennen muss wo ein Tier
gehalten wurde wie es gehalten wurde wo
es gemäste transportiert und letzten
Endes auch die Erzeugnisse
weiterverarbeitet wurden und deswegen
ist es gut und richtig dass man sich auf
den Weg gemacht hat eine haltungs- und
herkunftskennzeichen auf den Weg zu
bringen da gibt es wie das bei
gemeinsamen Gesetzesvorhaben immer der
Fall ist noch diskussionsgegenstände das
ist so aber ich bin sehr zuversichtlich
dass es damit gelingt tatsächlich die
Transparenz zu schaffen die wir brauchen
um den Verbraucher in die Pflicht zu
nehmen seinen Worten auch endlich Taten
folgen lassen zu können und meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren das ist mir
ganz besonders wichtiges Anliegen es
kann nicht sein dass wir auf der einen
Seite gemeinsam beklagendes durch
Klimawandel durch Flächenversiegelung
global immer weniger landwirtschaftliche
Fläche für die Produktion zur Verfügung
steht
auf der anderen Seite aber der Bedarf
nach hochwertigen Lebensmitteln auch
nach immer mehr Lebensmitteln steigt
weil immer mehr Menschen auf diesem
Globus Leben gleichzeitig wir aber
Landwirten es versagen die Technologien
auch zur Anwendung kommen zu lassen die
Sie benötigen um genau eben diesen
vermeintlichen diesen vermeintlichen
Gegensatz aufzulösen natürlich müssen
wir im Bereich innovative
Züchtungsmethoden Vorankommen natürlich
müssen wir auch bei
Pflanzenschutzmitteln vorankommen und
wir würden es uns in die eigene Tasche
lügen wenn wir den Kurs der letzten
Jahrzehnte fortsetzen würden wie es
leider auch unter ihrer Führung häufig
noch der Fall gewesen ist dass man sich
eben solche Innovationen versagt hat das
passt nicht ins Jahr 2023 wer den Hunger
in der Welt tatsächlich bekämpfen will
der macht das nicht über verzichtabelle
sondern darüber dass wir neue
Technologien in die Fläche bringen
müssen und so den Eltern bekämpfen
können vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Gero Hocker war das hier und die nächste
Rednerin ist Astrid Damerow
cdu/csu-fraktion und Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir diskutieren
hier den Einzelplan 10 Ernährung
Landwirtschaft und es tut mir leid Herr
Minister das ist die daran erinnern muss
und Fischerei sie sind auch Minister für
die deutsche Fischerei und haben in
ihrer Rede mit keiner einzige Zeile
unsere Fischerin und Fischer erwähnt
und das und das Herr Minister vor dem
Hintergrund das aktuell viele
Fischereibetriebe unverschuldet in eine
existenzbedrohende Krisensituation
geraten sind die Kosten für
Betriebsmittel insbesondere für
Treibstoff sind auf einem der atomniveau
dass ich Fangfahrten schlicht nicht mehr
lohnen die Hilferufe aus der Fischerei
sind und waren deutlich zu hören und
doch hat es eines monatelangen Kämpfen
bedurft um endlich
hierbeihilfen für die Fischerei zu
erreichen anfang April hatte meine
Fraktion den ersten Antrag für
Soforthilfen eingebracht Ende Mai hatte
der Bundestag 10 Millionen Euro im
Haushalt zu Krisenhilfe beschlossen und
erst im August wurden die ersten Gelder
ausbezahlt in ihrem Haushaltsentwurf
waren keine weiteren fischereihilfen für
das kommende Jahr vorgesehen
dankenswerterweise hat dies der
Bundestag über die Fraktionen hinweg
geheilt es sind also jetzt auch für 2023
weitere 10 Millionen Euro für
schnellhilfen für unsere Fischer
vorgesehen ich erwarte von Ihnen jetzt
Herr Minister dass ihr Ministerium aber
wirklich schnellstens die bestehenden
Vergabebedingungen überprüft und auf
Praxistauglichkeit überprüft und
entsprechend anpasst und das ganze bitte
schnell
einen weiteren zukunftsweisenden
finanziellen Ansatz für unsere Fischerei
sucht man in diesem gesamten Haushalt
jedoch trotzdem vergeblich der Verband
der deutschen Kutter und Küstenfischer
beispielsweise adressierte antipolitik
Forderungen beispielsweise nach
Absicherung ihrer Fanggebiete vor allem
vor dem Hintergrund des massiven Ausbaus
der offshorwind Energie ich frage Sie
Herr Minister sind Sie hierzu mit dem
Betroffenen Fischerinnen und Fischern im
Gespräch haben Sie darüber irgendein
Gespräch geführt vielleicht auch mit
ihrer Kollegin aus dem Umweltministerium
ebenso
ebenso ist dringend notwendig der Aufbau
eines praxistauglichen
modernisierungsfonds für die
Fischereiflotte und selbstverständlich
die konsequente Ausnutzung aller
Fördermöglichkeiten für unsere
Fischereibetriebe
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
ich hätte mir auch deutlich mehr
Leidenschaft bei einem grünen
Landwirtschaftsminister zum Thema
Tierschutz erwartet
zahlreiche Tierheime im Land haben mit
außergewöhnlichen Herausforderungen zu
kämpfen mancherorts sind es die
Haustiere ukrainischer Flüchtlinge
vielleicht sind es aber richtig
Betriebskosten und Nachwirkungen des
pandemiebedingten Haustier Booms während
der Deutsche Tierschutzbund aufgrund
stark steigender Belastung die
Schließung vieler tierheimisch
befürchtet spekuliert der Bundesminister
vor der Presse über eine Bundesstiftung
zur Förderung von Tierheim allerdings
ist diese Absicht in keiner Weise in
diesem Haushaltsentwurf auch nur
ansatzweise verankert gleichzeitig
lehnen die ampelparteien völlig ab
ambitionslos den von uns beantragt die
von uns beantragten 5 Millionen Euro für
unsere Tierheime im Jahr 2023 ab in 22
haben sie diese Mittel noch eingestellt
der Minister übergibt Moment aus diesem
aus diesen Mitteln pressewirksam
Förderbescheide aber in 2023 sind ihre
Ansicht nach ganz offensichtlich die
Tierheime alle aus dem Schneider das
kann so nicht sein
und parallel dazu Herr Minister finden
Sie aber trotzdem reichlich Geld in
ihrem Haushalt für die Schaffung eines
Tierschutzbeauftragten nichts zwei zwei
weitere Mitarbeitern und Sie können bis
heute auch auf unsere Anfrage hin nicht
genau erklären was dieser beauftragte
eigentlich genau zu tun soll zumal es ja
entsprechende Strukturen in ihrem
Ministerium durchaus gibt
als
Abgeordnete eines küstenwahlkreises
liegt mir natürlich auch der küsten- und
Hochwasserschutz am Herzen es fällt
zunächst positiv aus im auf im Haushalt
und als Schleswig-Holsteinerin sage ich
auch haben wir uns durchaus darüber
gefreut dass die Mittel für den
Küstenschutz deutlich erhöht wurden aber
Vorsicht im Gegenzug wird der
Bundesanteil Anteil an den Investitionen
in der Gemeinschaftsaufgabe Verbesserung
der agrar- und Küstenschutz der
Agrarstrukturen des Küstenschutzes um
rund 153 Millionen Euro gekürzt wir
haben es schon gehört hier insbesondere
zulasten des sonderrahmenplans zur
Förderung der ländlichen Entwicklung und
zwar um 30 Millionen Euro damit Herr
Minister zeigen sie ganz deutlich dass
ihre Regierung sie als
Landwirtschaftsminister nun wirklich
überhaupt nichts am Hut haben mit der
Zukunftsfähigkeit des ländlichen Raums
geschweige denn mit irgendwelchen
gleichwertigen Lebensverhältnissen ich
weiß geld ist nicht alles aber Geld ist
schon ganz schön viel und wenn wir da
vorankommen wollen dann muss das auch
finanziell unterlegt werden sonst werden
sie keine Kommune keine Stadt dazu
bekommen auch nur irgendetwas in diesem
in dieser Hinsicht zu machen also
abschließend
abschließend ist es nach wie vor so sie
verkünden und sie verkünden und es gibt
Ankündigungen und genau dabei bleibt es
leider muss ich sagen es bleibt dabei
als die mir sie sind ein
ankündigungsminister vielen Dank
Astrid Damerow vom Wahlkreis
Nordfriesland Dithmarschen Nord hat hier
natürlich auch noch mal auf die Küste
verwiesen
Karl Bär spricht nun für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Präsidentin liebe Kollegen und
Kolleginnen aus den demokratischen
Fraktionen es ist an der Zeit in dieser
Debatte über ein Thema zu sprechen das
bisher zu kurz gekommen ist und in dem
die Zukunft der Landwirtschaft schon
aufscheint nämlich den ökologischen
Landbau wenn man sich gerade anschaut
die Preise steigen dann steigen die
Preise für konventionelle Produkte
meistens mehr als für die Bioprodukte in
manchen Fällen im Supermarkt ist es
Bioprodukt schon billiger als das
konventionelle und wir fragen uns was
Erfahrung hat natürlich warum ist das so
und ich habe dazu zahlen hast
politischen Bericht der Bundesregierung
von 2019 noch unter Kollegen Glück ne
pro Hektar gibt ein konventioneller Hof
mehrstes 50-fache für Pestizide aus mehr
als das Sechsfache für Düngemittel mehr
als das Doppelte für den Flughafen von
Futter als ein bibetrieb das heißt der
Schock durch den russischen Angriff auf
die Ukraine der trifft die
konventionelle Landwirtschaft viel
härter letztendlich als die bio-kollegen
und in allen lehnung an Christian
Lindners Rede über die erneuerbaren
Energien könnte man die
Bio-Landwirtschaft eine
freiheits-landwirtschaft nennen sie
macht uns unabhängiger von fossilen
Energien von Dünger Mittel Importen
und von intensiv energieintensiv
produzierten Düngemitteln sie trägt
weniger zur Klimakatastrophe bei und ist
besser dafür gewappnet mit der klar zu
kommen und sie reduziert die externen
Kosten der Landwirtschaft und das ist
laut der Zukunftskommission
Landwirtschaft um die 90 Millionen
Milliarden Euro pro Jahr durch Schäden
in der Natur am Boden und am Wasser zum
Beispiel die Regierung hat sich das Ziel
gesetzt bis 20 30 Prozent der Fläche in
Deutschland auf Bio umzustellen und
deshalb schaffen wir ein
sonderrahmenplan von für Ökolandbau und
die Diversität in Höhe von 175 Millionen
Euro und wir fördern die Umstellung von
Kantinen wenn jetzt
hier ist ja niemand mehr aber doch es
ist noch Leute da wenn wir Leute zuhören
wenn Sie den Kantinen in den Schulen in
den Mensen in der Uni gerne mehr Bio
Essen der regionales Essen hätten
vegetarische Gerichte die was schmecken
wenn die Köche und Köchinnen sich
beraten lassen wollen dann fördern wir
aus diesem Haushalt das mit bis zu
35.000 Euro pro Stück
die Öko Prämien die Bäuerinnen und
Bauern wären und nach der Umstellung auf
Bio bekommen werden neu berechnet und
sie werden deutlich steigen und das
Bundesprogramm ökologischer Landbau
wird erhöht und zwar langfristig so dass
wir neue Projekte machen können für den
ökologischen Landbau das alles reicht
noch nicht
damit das Ziel erreicht wird müssen wir
in allen Programmen vom
Landwirtschaftsministerium ist es 30
Prozent sind durchziehen und alle
anderen Ministerien es sind aber
Staatssekretär da müssen auch ihren
Beitrag leisten wir müssen alle etwas
tun weil uns mehr Bio auch allen nützt
weil es uns widerstandsfähiger Macht
gegen die Krisen um uns herum vielen
Dank
Karl Bea war das hat hier gefragt ob er
noch Menschen zuhören und natürlich auch
wir übertragen das hier natürlich auch
noch Susanne mittagsprecherin für
Ernährung und Landwirtschaft der
SPD-Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ja das sind ja schon einige
Aspekte in diesem Haushalt dargestellt
worden gerne auch kritisch oder was
wieder mal fehlt immer schön den
Untergang vor Augen man darf aber auch
besonders in schwierigen Zeiten auch als
Opposition mal ein positiven Blick in
die Zukunft werfen das wird auch von
Bürgern auch von ihnen erwartet aber
nach so vielen Jahren
Regierungsbeteiligung mit
Schuldzuweisungen an anderen Blockade
von Zukunftsmöglichkeiten und als
letztes mal noch mal richtig Geld drauf
schütten sind unsere Erwartungen an ihre
Möglichkeiten offensichtlich zu hoch da
sind die Landwirten und Landwirte schon
erheblich weiter und da kann ich auch
sagen fragen Sie die doch einmal erst
kürzlich auf der EuroTier konnte man gut
erkennen welche Angebote besonders von
jungen Landwirten und Landwirten richtig
gut besucht waren das zeigt innovativ
und dem kommen wir dann im Haushalt auch
da und sei es bei der Förderung von
Innovationen im Bereich von nährstoffarm
für nährstoffreichen Organismen zum
Beispiel Insekten als Futter als
Lebensmittel den Umbau der Tierhaltung
mit innovativen Haltungssystem und zwar
sehr modernen Haltungssystem im Bereich
der Ackerbau Strategie wo ist nicht nur
im Vorhaben der nachhaltigen Ackerbau
Strategie geht sondern endlich auch mal
nach so viel Jahren von ihnen die
nachrangig betrachteten Bereiche
Gartenbau Sonderkulturen und
nachwachsende Rohstoffe
die Zukunft der Landwirtschaft muss mehr
in der Hand der Landwirte liegen die
Auslieferung an Großkonzerne war einfach
ein Irrweg und dabei helfen die
aufgestockten etas in der ländlichen
Entwicklung und regionalen Wertschöpfung
und jetzt auch besonders für die
Bereiche wie wohnen Dorfleben Kultur
Ehrenamt für Projekte der
Dezentralisierung mit etat-steigerung
und finanzieller Absicherung bis 2030
der besseren Unterstützung des
Bundesverbandes der Regionalbewegung und
wenn alles nicht hilft gegen die
Ausbeutung die Ombudsstelle gegen
unlautere Handelspraktiken wird auch
endlich eingerichtet
so zur Landwirtschaft gehört allerdings
auch ist schon erwähnt worden und es ist
sehr wohl betrachtet worden die
seewirtschaft die Fischerei die
Aquakulturen auch hier ist mal endlich
Zukunftsorientierung angesagt mit einem
neuen Forschungsschiff das ist schon
erwähnt worden einer zentralen
Anlaufstelle für Aquakulturen auf sie
und an Land mit Forschung und regionaler
Wertschöpfung festgeschrieben im Etat
Nutztierhaltung im Rahmen von regionale
Produktion und Verwertungsketten die
gehören da immer zu und als Überbrückung
dahin für das Überleben der Fischerei
sonst kommen die da gar nicht mehr an
mit 10 Millionen Euro Hilfen das ist
nicht wenig und mehr als jemals zuvor
und gerade in der Landwirtschaft hat die
Kreislaufwirtschaft einen hohen
Stellenwert und wird weiter ausgebaut
über die Tierhaltung energieverzeugung
die Düngung Futter oder
Lebensmittelerzeugung wird diesem
Gedanken Rechnung getragen und wenn die
in Zeiten drohender Energieknappheit die
regenerativen Möglichkeiten in der
Landwirtschaft voll ausgenutzt werden
müssen aber durch Strom Erlös
Abschöpfung ein Zuschussgeschäft werden
könnte dann kann ich nur sagen auch wenn
du die ersten anderthalb Jahre sind hat
das massive negative Folgen und deswegen
würde ich sagen dass die gleichbehaltung
Behandlung von Biomethan und biogast
eigentlich nur voll gerechtig wäre
und ja wahrscheinlich kommt bei dem
einen oder anderen Begeisterung auch bei
der Opposition da sind Sie ja derzeit
auch gerne wegen der hohen Strom- und
Gaspreise zum Beispiel im Bereich
Bäckereien oder Schlachtereien unterwegs
allerdings haben sie leider dafür gegen
die dafür notwendigen Maßnahmen im
Gesetz Ja gestimmt und deswegen passt
das jetzt mit der Wirklichkeit nicht so
sie gegen die Erstattung von
Abschlagszahlungen unternehmerhilfen und
die Deckelung der Preise wir haben jetzt
dafür gesorgt dass nicht nur die
Mittelstandsbetriebe und das ist nun mal
in der Landwirtschaft wie Molkerei
Bäckerei Mühlen und Schlachthöfe
gestützt werden sondern auch unter
Glasanbau und Aufzucht in der
Tierhaltung
und zum Schluss trotzdem wichtig wollen
wir uns ja nicht nur mit unseren
Problemen hier im Land beschäftigen in
unserem Etat sind auch Mittel für die
bilaterale technische Zusammenarbeit mit
dem Ausland
Problemlagen aber auch was möglich ist
haben wir erst kürzlich auf einer
Delegationsreise nach Kenia und Sambia
festgestellt und sich von zwei
Regenzeiten und drei Ernten auf fünf
ausgefallene Regenzeiten umzustellen das
ist schon eine existenzielle
Herausforderung die nicht leicht zu
meistern ist und die Aufstockung also
die veränderten Anbau Methoden Rückgriff
auf regionale Sorten können ernten
sichern und ein ganz wichtiger Fokus ist
dort die Frauen in der Landwirtschaft
die dafür zuständig sind für die
Landwirtschaft Ernährung Gesundheit
Bildung und wertschöpfen was für eine
große Aufgabe die Frauen da übernehmen
ist nicht zu unterschätzen und das
wollen wir auch unterstützen die
Aufstockung des Etats ebenso für die
Soforthilfe für die FAU oder Aufbau noch
nicht erfolgen konnte sind
zukunftsträchtig und diese ganze
Bandbreite das ist die Zukunft der
Landwirtschaft
für die cdu/csu folgt nun Max
Straubinger
[Applaus]
geschätzte frau Präsidentin wird die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Ende der Debatte ist es durchaus mit
angebracht noch mal etwas
zusammenzufassen und Frau Kollegin
Mittag sie haben da mit uns aufgefordert
auch als Opposition etwas optimistischer
sozusagen also in die Zukunft zu blicken
und auch Optimismus zu verbreiten aber
auf Grundlagen der
haushaltsexsätze die sie gebildet haben
fehlt uns leider Gottes dieser
Optimismus denn dieser Haushalt der
bedeutete eigentlich nur mehr
Belastungen und weniger
Planungssicherheit für unsere
Landwirtinnen und Landwirte und dies
zeigt sich sehr deutlich keine
Entlastung bei den
Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen
Mehrbelastungen und mehr Bürokratie beim
tiermittelgesetz keine Planungen wie für
die Viehhalter bei der Weide Verwaltung
wie man mit Wolf umgeht keine
Zielrichtung in keinster Weise erkennbar
und wenn ich an die
pflanzenschutzrichtlinie der EU denke
dann traut mir sowieso bei dieser
Bundesregierung in der Umsetzung also wo
soll da der Optimismus herkommen Frau
Kollegin das und vor allen Dingen sie
sind ja angetreten und es zeigt sich ja
durch alle Äußerungen insbesondere aus
der grünen Seite aber auch von der SPD
das ist letztendlich nur um den Abbau
der Tierhaltung in Deutschland geht
Extensivierung das ist ihre Zielmarke
der ganzen Politik und das kann meines
Erachtens aber nicht sehr Optimismus für
die Landwirte also mit hervorrufen und
bedeuten und es zeigt sich dass sie mit
einem lächerlichen Betrag einen Umbau
der Tierhaltung hier herbeiführen wollen
in Deutschland sie wurde ja
vielfältigster
Kommission hat es ja beziffert wie viel
finanz vermittelt dafür notwendig sind
sie setzen 150 Millionen je ja vier
Jahre lang angeblich da als
zielorientierte Marke ein ja da wird
sich kein einziger Landwirt überhaupt
darum kümmern können sich in ein solches
Programm mit einzuschreiben wo soll da
der Optimismus herkommen Frau Kollegin
Mittag das muss man ja mitziehen das
bedeutet auch dass sie letztendlich ja
anhalten hier die die Tierhaltung zu
vermindern in Deutschland um ihre
CO2-Ziele zu erreichen und Methanausstoß
Ziele zu erreichen und dergleichen mehr
das ist ihnen offensichtlich wichtiger
wie eine vernünftige Tierhaltung mit in
unseren mit in unserem schönen Land hier
zu organisieren und es zeigt sich die
warnenden Stimmen aus der
Fleischindustrie waren ja in der
vergangenen Woche ja feststellbar hier
wird klar und deutlich festgestellt dass
es möglicherweise bald einen Mangel aus
einheimischer Fleischerzeugung in
Deutschland geben wird
und das führt hinterher zu steigendem
Preisen bei den Verbraucherinnen und
Verbrauchern ist mag man wollen und bin
ich überzeugt die grüne Fraktion will
das Herbeiführen natürlich weil sie
glaubt dass damit also mehr gesunde
Ernährung für die für die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher übrig
bleibt mehr Körner für die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher und
damit natürlich also
sogenannt mehr Ökoprodukte liebe Frau
Kollegin sie hätten uns begleiten sollen
bleibt begleiten sollen wenn sie ihren
sehr geehrter Zimmer aufgebrochen
Vegetarismus und Veganismus mit der sich
darstellt in der Regel und das mauert
mit Tomaten mit Zucchini mit der
Mitte oder sonstigen Dingen
Steckrüben rote Rüben vielleicht es wäre
noch gut weil es einheimische Produkte
sind
advokato und und aus aller Herren
Ländern der Welt eingeführt zu
unmöglichsten zu unmöglichsten
Bedingungen produziert wir konnten es
wir konnten es bei unserer
ausschussreise mit betrachten die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie können ja
dann ihre teilnehmenden Kolleginnen mit
befragen das Grundwasser abgesenkt wird
auf 20% des ursprünglichen Zustands das
ist ein naturfregel der dort betrieben
wird nicht nur Friebel sondern es ist
unerträglich und wenn diese Produkte
dann bei uns eingeführt werden zu
niedrigsten Preisen mit einem Bio-Siegel
versehen obwohl Pflanzenschutzmittel in
umfangreichsten Umfang also mit auch
eingesetzt werden dann ist es noch sogar
eine zugelassene Verbrauchertäuschung
die stattfindet und mit diesen mit
diesem Produktion letztendlich hier auch
die heimische Produktion von Gemüse und
von sonstigen Bereichen hier dann dauert
nicht mehr unter unterminiert wird und
das ist ihre Politik denn zieht treten
ja ständig an das Fleisch letztendlich
aus dem
verkehrskreislauf zu verbieten sie haben
zwar noch kein Gesetz eingebracht aber
mir schwand ja übles wenn ich jetzt
lesen durfte letzte Woche dass er der
kötterer des Deutschen Bundestages
gekündigt hat und jetzt eine neue
Ausschreibung stattfindet und sich um
diese Ausschreibung die Kollegin kühnaus
kümmert und und somit den und somit
somit den Koalitionsvertrag umsetzen
will dass dann bedeutet dass nur noch
zweimal am Tag
zweimal in der Woche Fleisch angeboten
werden darf ich sag das ist mir dann der
Weg zu der Liebe das sage ich ganz
ehrlich gehen Sie mal propagiert haben
bei einem Wahlkampf des sage ich also so
ist es hörte Damen und Herren das ist
das Zeichen setzen an die Landwirte in
unserem Land wir wollen keine
Tierhaltung haben wir wollen von
Steckrüben Leben damit können wir aber
keine zukunftsorientierte Landwirtschaft
hier auch mit aufbauen und deshalb fährt
die Damen und Herren können wir liebe
Frau Kollegin Mittag nicht optimistisch
in die Zukunft blicken
[Applaus]
Straubinger und ja kriegt hier Applaus
das voll die meisten nicht von
Steckrüben allein erleben möchten
nun als nächstes sie sitzt im Ausschuss
für Ernährung und Landwirtschaft von
Bündnis 90 den Grünen und ist damit
natürlich in der gleichen Partei wie
auch der zuständige Minister in der
Bereinigungssitzung des
Haushaltsausschusses gab es übrigens
noch einmal 75 Millionen Euro zusätzlich
unter anderem 3 Millionen Euro für die
Unterstützung nachhaltiger gesunder
innovativer ernährungs-
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
haben den Haushalt nicht nur
ökologischer gemacht wir haben den
Haushalt nicht nur sozialer gemacht nein
wir haben ihn nämlich auch regionaler
gemacht Herr Straubinger im
Koalitionsvertrag haben wir es
vereinbart wir werden regionale
Wertschöpfungsketten stärken das ist
eben nicht aus Spanien kommt und in
diesem Haushalt haben wir die Weichen
dafür gestellt nach jahrzehntelangem
wachse oder weiche die fortwährenden
Konzentrationsprozesse in Richtung
industrieller Produktion in der
Landwirtschaft und auch in der
Verarbeitung das müssen wir endlich
stoppen denn jeder Hof zählt jede
Handwerksbäckerei zählt jede Fleischerei
zählt und auch jede kleine Mühle zählt
30 Prozent der Bäckereien und
Fleischereien haben wir in den letzten
zehn Jahren verloren und von rund 20.000
Mühlen in 1951 haben wir heute nur noch
185 und ich sage nur drei Worte 16 Jahre
cdu/cs
wir handeln das bisherige Bundesprogramm
ländliche Entwicklung haben die
umbenannt in ein Bundesprogramm nennt
sich Entwicklung und regionale
Wertschöpfung und auch aufgestockt und
diesem Programm damit einen neuen
Schwerpunkt gegeben weg von der bloßen
Entwicklung des ländlichen Raums hin zu
souveräner eigener Wertschöpfung auf dem
Land durch Obst und Gemüse
beispielsweise zu ländlicher
Wertschöpfung außerdem haben wir 12
Millionen Euro für ein Modellregion
Wettbewerb ernährungswende in der Region
in den Haushalt gestellt um über so
einen Wettbewerb möglichst viele
Regionen Stadt Land Regionen zu
erreichen in denen wir ganzheitlich vom
Acker über die Verarbeitung vor Ort bis
zum Teller eine für Mensch und Planeten
gesunde ernährungswände einleiten
die Eiweißstrategie haben wir um 4
Millionen Euro aufgestockt in die
regionale ökologische ernährungswende
schaffen wir nur wenn wir auch in der
pflanzenbasierten ernährungsschwerpunkte
setzen und mit diesen Mitteln werden wir
Forschung Anbau und auch
Erzeugergemeinschaften stärken
erste Priorität ist aber jetzt in dieser
Krise die regionalen Betriebe gut durch
die Krise zu bekommen dafür haben wir
mit dem wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds
200 Milliarden in den Haushalt gestellt
als Soforthilfe übernimmt der Bund jetzt
im Dezember die Abschlagszahlung für Gas
für kleine mittlere Betriebe das wird
vor allen Dingen auch energieintensive
Lebensmittelhandwerk entlasten aber auch
natürlich die Landwirte und die
Industrie bekommt diesen Abschlag
nämlich eben nicht
2023 werden wir die kleinen Betriebe
dann über die gaspreisbremse und die
strompreisbremse entlasten und zwar ohne
winterlücke mit fairen Bedingungen im
Vergleich zu Industrie und das war uns
besonders wichtig
und außerdem haben wir jetzt im Haushalt
100 Millionen verankert im Klima und
transformationsfonds für kleinst und
Kleinbetriebe insbesondere im
Lebensmittelhandwerk damit sie ihre
Produktionsanlagen zum Beispiel Öfen von
Gas oder Öl auf Strom oder erneuerbare
Energien umrüsten können so können Sie
nämlich von fossilen Energien
Energieträgern langfristig unabhängig
werden und haben wieder eine Zukunft
meine Damen und Herren wir reden nicht
nur wir handeln aus ländlicher
Entwicklung machen wir nämlich jetzt
echte ländliche nachhaltige
Wertschöpfung herzlichen Dank
nächste Rednerin ist Peggy Schierenbeck
für die SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Damen und
Herren ich stehe heute vor ihnen und bin
sehr sehr froh ich bin froh über 12
Millionen Euro für eine Maßnahme die für
die Gesundheit unserer Gesellschaft
entscheidend ist es ist der Modellregion
in Wettbewerb für eine gesunde und
nachhaltige
Gemeinschaftsverpflegung vier Punkte
möchte ich dabei besonders hervorheben
der Zugang zu gesunder Ernährung ist
eine Frage sozialer Gerechtigkeit wir
brauchen gleiche und faire
Gesundheitschancen für alle wir stärken
die Bildung im Bereich Ernährung wir
sagen der ernährungsarmut den Kampf an
warum brauchen wir dafür ein
Modellregion in Wettbewerb auch bei uns
in Deutschland gibt es Hunger nicht
unbedingt hungermangels weniger Kalorien
sondern vielmehr einen versteckten
Hunger weil das Essen nicht genügend
Nährstoffe enthält unserem Körper nicht
das gibt was er eigentlich braucht die
nicht gesund genug ist das ist
ernährungsarmut meine Damen und Herren
und dieses Problem der ernährungsarmut
findet in Deutschland statt
ernährungsarmut ist also ein Mangel und
Fehlernährung ernährungsbedingte
Krankheiten Übergewicht und
Nährstoffmangel sind die Folge
ernährungsarme ist oft armutsbedingt
weil zum Beispiel preisgünstige
Lebensmittel meist sehr energiedicht
aber nährstoffarm sind für mich zeigt
das ganz klar wie stark soziale
Gerechtigkeit und Ernährung
Zusammenhängen hier sehe ich unseren
Auftrag zu handeln
diesen Auftrag sehe ich insbesondere bei
unseren Kindern und Jugendlichen das
bedeutet ah jetzt habe ich die falsche
Seite denn ich finde es alarmieren etwa
jede sechste Kind in Deutschland ist
übergewichtig oder sogar adipös Corona
hat die Ernährungssituation nicht besser
gemacht ganz im Gegenteil wir wissen
dass sich die Zahlen zu Übergewicht und
ungesunde Ernährung noch verschlechtert
haben vor allem die Kinder sind die
gesundheitlichen Auswirkungen einer
Fehlernährung dramatisch zum Beispiel
schränkt ist ihre körperliche und
geistige Entwicklung ein zum Beispiel
leiden sie an Diabetes oder sogar
Bluthochdruck zum Beispiel kommen Sie
durch Übergewicht viel früher in die
Pubertät man stellte sich das bitte
einmal vor zum Beispiel leidet ihre
seelisches Wohlbefinden wir wissen wie
sehr Körper und Psyche Zusammenhängen
wir sehen also satt sein allein reicht
nicht aus wir müssen was müssen wir also
tun wir müssen die
Gemeinschaftsverpflegung in den Blick
nehmen täglich nehmen 17 Millionen
Menschen in Deutschland an diesem Ort
ihr Essen zu sich das heißt ganz in den
Kantinen und Menschen in Kitas Schulen
Universitäten Betrieben
Senioreneinrichtungen und Krankenhäusern
deshalb ist es ein so großer Hebel für
uns
das Ziel muss sein eine leckere gesunde
hochwertige und nachhaltige Verpflegung
für alle gerade jetzt in Zeiten
steigender Lebensmittelpreise ist das
besonders wichtig eine gesunde Ernährung
darf nicht zum Luxusgut werden hohe
Preise für gesunde Lebensmittel sind ein
Brandbeschleuniger für ernährungsarmut
der Modellregion in Wettbewerb ist
deshalb eine riesengroße Chance weil er
uns an dieser Stelle ermöglicht als Bund
Einfluss zu nehmen und Vorbilder zu
schaffen er zeigt Wege wie eine Fähre
und sozialgerechte Ernährung der Zukunft
gelingen kann
das bedeutet Kantinen und Mensen sollen
wohlfühlorte sein denken Sie nur an
ihren letzten Besuch in Ihrem
Lieblingsrestaurant ein Ort an dem sie
sich gerne aufhalten Energie tanken und
genießen so soll es auch in Kantinen
sein denn Essen ist nicht nur
Nahrungsaufnahme Essen ist Genuss soll
Spaß machen ermöglicht Begegnungen und
man kann so viel darüber lernen das
bedeutet wiederum das Kantinen und
Menschen zu lernen und Erlebnisräumen
werden müssen stellen Sie sich vor Sie
sind in der Kantine ein Ort an dem sie
sich in Zukunft wohlfühlen werden und
lernen dabei etwas über das was sie
gerade essen was Nahrung mit ihrem
Körper und ihrer Gesundheit zu tun hat
um ihn die Qual der Essensauswahl zu
erleichtern schaffen wir faire
ernährungsumgebungen also ein Umfeld
dass die gesunde Wahl zur leichteren
macht weil das alles noch nicht genug
ist muss auch die Qualität stimmen da
stellen die Qualitätsstandards der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für Ernährung
sicher und weil wir unsere
Landwirtschaft so wichtig ist sollen
regionale saisonale ökologisch erzeugte
Lebensmittel Vorrang haben auch das
Klima ist mir wichtig deswegen stärken
wir das pflanzenangebote eine Pflanzen
betonte Angebot das bedeutet mehr
attraktive Speisen aus Gemüse Rohkost
Salat und Hülsenfrüchten und weniger
Fleisch auch das ist eine Empfehlung der
DGE und ihren welpenwelt dankt es uns
meine Damen und Herren ich will dass sie
wissen was ich weiß Ernährung ist der
effektivste Hebel um unsere Gesundheit
zu verbessern und nachhaltiger zu leben
es ist unser Auftrag unsere
Fürsorgepflicht all diese Erkenntnisse
über Ernährung umzusetzen die
Einrichtungen in der
gemeinschaftsverpflegungen sind dafür
der beste Ort der Modellregion in
Wettbewerb dient uns als Instrument für
die ernährungswende damit alle die
gleiche Chance auf ein gesundes Leben
haben danke
wecke war das für die SPD und der
nächste Renner Stefan Seidler er ist
fraktionslos weil Mitglied des Süd
Schleswig schon wählerverband
und hat nun drei Minuten Redezeit liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist schön
ihnen zuzuhören wenn man noch kein
Abendessen gehabt hat aber vielen Dank
dafür lassen mich aber zu diesem
Einzelplan ein besonderen Blick auf
einen ganz anderen Bereich werfen
nämlich den Küstenschutz für den ihr
Haus auch zuständig ist Herr Ministerium
hier vor wenigen Tagen am 12 und 13
November gedachten wir im Norden entlang
der Ostküste den Opfer
Opfern des großen Sturm Hochwasser von
1872 damals verloren über 270 Menschen
über Nacht ihr Leben tausende Familien
wurden obdachlos ganze Orte wurden
weggespült in Flensburg in Eckernförde
und in anderen Orten und unsere Ostküste
stiegen die Pegel um über drei Meter
heute wissen wir dass zu hohe
Pegelstände Hochwasser aufgrund des
Anstiegs des Meeresspiegels und des
Klimawandels bald häufiger bei uns
auftreten werden
die Menschen im Norden sind alarmiert
bei einer Katastrophe wie vor 150 Jahren
werden heute ein Vielfaches an Opfern
und Schäden zu beklagen
100.000 Menschen und Milliarden an
Sachwerten sind an unseren Küsten
bedroht das zeigt Küstenschutz hat
höchste Priorität verdient
die Aufstockung
die Aufstockung um 25 Millionen Euro für
den Kostenschutz im vorliegenden
Haushalt ist eine begrüßenswerte
Steigerung und ein klares Signal von
ihnen vielen Dank aber liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen es ist leider nur ein
kleiner Tropfen in die große Nordsee
oder in unserer Ostsee die Ausgaben vor
denen wir stehen für die Ertüchtigung
von Deichen Sicherung von
Dünenlandschaften für Entwässerung für
Schleusen sind massiv und sie werden
steigen zudem bekommt einen
strukturelles zu den kommt ein
strukturelles Problem bei der
Finanzierung der Bund fördert nämlich
nur neu Baumaßnahmen und keinen
Unterhalt
Küstenschutz ist eine Aufgabe von Bund
und Ländern es braucht gemeinsame
Verantwortung auch beim Unterhalt
aber und jetzt kommt ein Satz der in der
haushaltswoche vermutlich nicht so oft
fällt mehr Geld alleine wird das Problem
nicht lösen auch der Fachkräftemangel
trifft den Küstenschutz tatkräftige
ExpertInnen für den Deichbau sind sehr
umworben liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
beim Küstenschutz stehen wir durch den
Klimawandel vor einer Jahrhundertaufgabe
trotzdem verlieren wir uns noch zu oft
im politischen und administrativen
kleinen zwischen Berlin den
Küstenländern und den Kommunen im Norden
wir brauchen Lösungen für die Menschen
an der Küste und klare Strukturen ich
denke in erster Linie an eine bessere
Koordinierung wir müssen die
strukturellen Probleme des
Küstenschutzes gemeinsam anpacken wir
brauchen eine koordinierende Stelle Herr
Minister ich denke es ist Zeit für einen
Bundesbeauftragten oder eine
Bundesbeauftragte für den Küstenschutz
vielen Dank
Stefan Seidler war das bekommt ihr auch
Applaus von den anderen Fraktionen und
damit kommen wir zur letzten Rednerin im
diesem Einzelplan Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft das ist Franziska Kersten
für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
Ernährung und Landwirtschaft sind
Grundlage jeder Gesellschaft und da sind
wir uns sicherlich alle einig weil die
Erzeugung von Lebensmitteln bei allen
Menschen elementar ist für alle Menschen
elementar ist hat auch jeder seine
Meinung und deshalb gibt es nicht nur
hier im Plenum widerstreitende
Meinung dazu wieder streitende
Interessen pardon wir haben die Balance
zwischen ökologischer Nachhaltigkeit und
ökonomischer Tragfähigkeit im Blick nur
so können wir auf Dauer einheimische
Lebensmittelerzeugung und lebenswerte
ländliche Räume wirklich gesichert
das setzen wir mit dem Agrarhaushalt
2023 um wie die Beiträge der
Vorrednerinnen der Koalition ja schon
eindrucksvoll nachgewiesen haben
die Verhandlung waren anspruchsvoll und
für den erfolgreichen Abschluss möchte
ich insbesondere unser
Berichterstatterin im Haushaltsausschuss
es dadurch ja herzlichen
wir wollen Zukunft gestalten das gelingt
nur mit Zukunftstechnologien nicht
umsonst hat schon der agrarsprecher
meiner Fraktion in der letzten
Legislaturperiode immer wieder
Digitalisierung gefordert wie einige von
ihnen vielleicht auch noch wissen jetzt
sind wir einen bedeutenden Schritt
vorangekommen die vorgesehenen
Haushaltsmittel für die Digitalisierung
konnten in den Verhandlungen um 3
Millionen auf nunmehr 23,5 Millionen
Euro erhöht werden
außerdem ist verpflichten
festgeschrieben dass aus den Mitteln
erstens die Erstellung einer
landwirtschaftsdatenbank 2.0 und die
Schaffung einer tiergesundheitsdatenbank
zur risikoorientierten Überwachung von
Tiergesundheit und Tierwohl gefördert
werden
diese Datenbanken haben zwei Ziele von
der öffentlichen Hand bereitgestellte
Daten ermöglichen erst die breite
Anwendung von smartensystemen zur
Landbewirtschaftung unabhängig von
großen Konzernen das trägt zu einer
punktgenauen Düngung und auch zu einem
präziseren Einsatz von
Pflanzenschutzmitteln bei und damit
sorgen die Datenbanken für
gesellschaftlich geforderte Transparenz
und auch für mehr Akzeptanz für die
Landwirtschaft
noch ein paar Worte zu einem
südostdeutschland sehr wichtigen Thema
den bvv-flächen im Koalitionsvertrag
haben wir vereinbart dass die
verbliebenen rund 90.000 Hektar nicht
mehr weit meist bieten veräußert sondern
vorrangig an nachhaltige und ökologisch
wirtschaftende Betriebe verpachtet
werden dies wird jetzt auch so umgesetzt
hier mit leisten wir einen
entscheidenden Beitrag zur
Nahrungsmittelproduktion bei
gleichzeitigen Fokus auf Arten und
Klimaschutz
die Verpackungs die
verpachtungskriterien werden wir jetzt
zügig gemeinsam mit den ostdeutschen
Bundesländern erarbeiten damit wir
spätestens 2023 klare Regeln für die
Landwirtschaft haben sie sehen also wir
wollen Zukunft nicht nur gestalten
sondern tun dies auch und haben dabei
Mensch und Natur im Blick vielen Dank
das war also die Debatte zum Einzelplan
ziehen jetzt gibt's hier einen
Änderungsantrag der Unionsfraktion der
erst einmal abgestimmt wird wo es um die
landwirtschaftliche Unfallversicherung
geht
in der ausschussfassung hierzu liegt ein
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
auf Drucksache
4.550 vor wer stimmt dafür dass es die
cdu/csu und die AFD und die Linke wer
stimmt dagegen dass es die SPD Bündnis
90 die Grünen und die FDP Enthaltung
sehe ich keine dann ist der an
Änderungsantrag abgelehnt dann kommen
wir jetzt zur Abstimmung über den
Einzelplan 10 Bundesministerium für
Ernährung und Landwirtschaft in der
ausschussfassung wer stimmt dafür
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
linke cdu/csu und die AFD Enthaltung
sehe ich keine der Einzelplan 10 ist
angenommen und das bedeutet im Jahr 2023
gibt es
7,25 Milliarden Euro für das
Bundesministerium für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft